c'est parti bonsoir à tous et désolé
pour le petit retard lie à quelques
inconvénients associés au transport en
commun qui sont évidemment comme vous le
savez les choses a privilégié par
rapport à la voiture sauf que de temps
en temps comme la voiture ça tombe en
panne voilà donc j'ai eu droit de pannes
successives
voilà c est que les places de
probabilité on est droit de temps en
temps oui j'ai eu un petit peu de retard
et j'en suis désolé je vais démarrer le
les questions qui ont été posées pour
cette édition avec des questions qui
concernent le haut conseil pour le
climat puisque ces nouveautés on va dire
par rapport à la dernière fois et je la
première question qui m'a été posée sur
le haut conseil pour le climat
c'est où en est il et quelles sont les
échéances à venir
alors le haut conseil pour le climat a
été annoncée par emmanuel macron à
l'occasion de la présentation de la peep
et au le 27 novembre dernier sinon
maryvonne et à ce moment là a été
annoncé la composition à la fois de sa
présidente corinne le quéré et puis des
douze autres membres dont treize à table
à l'époque qui le composent depuis il y
en a deux qui sont partis vivre une vie
ailleurs puisqu'il y avait dedans pascal
canfin qui s'est présenté aux
européennes
et puis pierre larrouturou qui a
également souhaité vivre sa vie en
politique
enfin on en quelque chose qui ressemble
à de la politique plutôt que plutôt que
d'y rester
le haut conseil pour le climat se réunit
en gros une fois par mois fait même pas
en gros tu restes c'est une fois par
mois et puis entre les réunions donc
c'est une réunion d'une journée
et puis entre les réunions on s'échange
des documents on travaille passeport
sachant qu'on a un premier livrables à
rendre dans les semaines qui viennent
très exactement la dernière semaine de
juin
qui est un premier avis sur la
trajectoire française en matière
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
le mandat qui a été confié au conseil
tout le climat c'est d'avoir un avis ça
c'est quelque chose qui va être très
facile à faire en france avoir un avis
c'est quand même un sport national donc
notre notre mandat c'est avoir un avis
sur la trajectoire française en matière
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre bien
évidemment il ya dans 25 façon de lire
cette d'appliquer ce moment là on peut
très bien en un paragraphe rendre notre
apport en disant on n'est pas dans les
clous puis voilà on n'est pas dans les
clous au revoir monsieur dame on peut
dire des choses qui sont pourquoi à
notre avis est ce qu'on n'est pas dans
les clous
après on peut dire des choses encore
plus il ya encore un cran plus loin qui
est qu est ce que ça te demanderais
d'être dans les clous et en fait c'est
là qu'on commence à tomber dans les
choses difficiles parce que ce qu'il
faut faire là il faut faire la part des
choses entre ce qui est physiquement
impossible ce qui est physiquement
possible mais qui demande des
contreparties sociales et économiques
qui sont considérés aujourd'hui comme
inacceptable voilà on va on va avoir un
rôle difficile de pédagogie soit dit en
passant il pédagogie sur le problème qui
n'est pas toujours faite par le
gouvernement
donc ce donc le mandat du haut conseil
c'est de faire ce genre de choses
alors encore une fois avec une réunion
tous les mois plus un peu de temps
intermédiaires et avec des gens qui sont
pour l'essentiel tous bénévoles
quand il est question soit de payer
m'enfin bon pratique pour le moment
personne de payer donc on est tous
bénévoles on va pas faire quelque chose
qui est en volume massif et on se fait
aider par une équipe permanente donc au
conseil à ce qu'on appelle un
secrétariat qui est en fait une espèce
de cabinet de conseil interne qui a été
recruté donc il a un directeur exécutif
qui est un salarié à plein temps alors
que la présidente ait les temps partiels
et la présidente soit dit en passant
elle est également membre de
l'équivalent français du haut conseil
pour le climat qui est le climate
challenge committee anglais est en fait
une des structures qui a inspiré le haut
conseil pour le climat c'est le climate
change committee anglais qu'il ya une
feuille de route qui est un peu plus
ambitieuse et un peu plus de pouvoirs
que ceux qu'on a nous mais enfin on sent
qu'il ya une inspiration autrement
donc corinne le quéré ll est censé
passer deux jours par semaine de jour
parlement pardon sur notre affaire donc
on a un secrétariat
c'est à dire une équipe permanente avec
donc un directeur exécutif qui est plein
temps qui a été nommé il ya quelques
semaines
et puis un responsable des études qui a
été recruté si les informations sont
correctes je crois que je pas si son nom
est déjà annoncées ou pas et puis il y
aura une équipe d'analystes alors un
analyste dans le jargon c'est quelqu'un
qui fait pour le conte des membres du
haut conseil
un des analyses qu'on lui demande de
faire par exemple dans les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre des transports
quelle est la part qui vient de
l'essence du diesel des poids lourds des
utilitaires des trottinettes et je sais
pas quoi penser des calculs qu'on va
faire nous mêmes aussi des analyses pour
la coiffure de même on commandera ça en
interne
et si on interne il n'y arrive pas sûr
qu'ils aient pas la compétence soit qui
n'ait pas les expertises il y aura un
budget externe d'études qui pourra être
commandée pour l'heure on sait ce qu'il
veut pose évidemment pour la question
que chacun d'entre vous immédiatement
après le temps des liens puisque ou bien
ces études sont passés au billard
cabinet de la place cp1 carbone 4 et on
m'accuse de collusion ou bien ils sont
passés à quelqu'un d'autre est
certainement bien fait donc je suis
vraiment très très endettés comme vidéo
a part ça le haut conseil va être créée
par un article de la loi sur l'énergie
qui va être discutée dans pas très
longtemps là au parlement et nous aurons
un décret qui va préciser nos
applications pour le moment nous sommes
d'une ligne budgétaire d'un ministère je
crois que nous sommes dudit budget
heures du premier ministre est une des
revendications internes ce que c'est
qu'en france on est bien loin des
revendications et des revendications un
terme qu'on a c'est en fait de devenir
une entité indépendante qui du coup
aurait son budget voté par le parlement
et non pas arbitré de manière
discrétionnaire par un ministre sur son
propre budget
voilà donc où on est le haut conseil est
ce qu'il fait et du coup ça va me
permettre de répondre à un certain
nombre de questions sur ce qui ne va
malheureusement pas refaire alors qu'est
ce que le haut conseil ne va pas faire
et bien il ne sera pas sollicité par le
ministre en charge de la transition où
ses collègues tous les quatre matins
pour donner un avis sur tel ou tel
projet de ceci ou de cela parce que ça
c'est quelque chose qu'ils demanderaient
un temps que nous n'avons évidemment pas
donc ça n'exclut pas que le titre
personnel un certain nombre d'entre nous
puisse avoir des relations avec le monde
politique dans lequel on raconte des
choses les machins mais par contre le
rôle lui au conseil ne sera absolument
pas structurés etc santé la politique
française dans la mesure où enfin pas au
travers de cette casquette en tout cas
on essaye de fuir modestement au travers
de schiste est quelque part aussi au
travers de carbone 4 en mettant des
connaissances sur la place mais c'est
pas quelque chose qui sera dans le
mandat du haut conseil en tant que tel
la deuxième chose que le haut conseil
forget nous fera pas c'est que nos avis
seront unanimes on a décidé d'adopter la
dite la discipline du giec
j'ai envie de dire vous savez que dans
les résumé pour décideurs du giec
chaque chaque mot est discutée et chaque
mot est votée par les représentants des
états et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument indispensable pour que
derrière chaque représentant de
l'institution puisse lui tout seul et de
son côté défendre la totalité de ce qui
a été adopté ce qu'à partir du moment où
il ya des divergences et un vote à la
majorité par exemple la totalité des
membres de saurait plus solidaire des
conclusions or il faut absolument que la
totalité des membres soient solidaires
des conclusions donc chacun de notre
côté on soit en mesure d'aller défendre
le rapport du haut conseil
donc on a décidé qu'on mettrait dedans
que des choses qui sont unanimes que si
on avait des divergences de vue on
ferait part de ses divergences et donc
s'il ya des divergences irréductibles
j'ai envie de dire c'est des sujets
qu'on abordera pas dans les rapports
donc ça ça répond à une question qui
était posée est ce que on va avoir un
rôle d'expert auprès du gouvernement la
réponse est non
on a plutôt un rôle de censeur
c'est à dire qu'en fait on est chargée
de donner un avis ex post
un peu comme la cour des comptes donne
un avis sur la manière dont on a géré
l'argent public eh bien nous on va
donner un avis sur la façon dont les
choses se passent en matière de gaz à
effet de serre on espère évidemment que
ça va donner des idées pour faire
différemment
donc est-ce qu'on va amener la base
scientifique indispensable 150 citoyens
tirés au sort pour la convention
citoyenne sur le climat et bien la
réponse à ce stade c'est que je ne sais
pas alors je ne sais pas si je ne sais
pas parce que j'ai été distrait et que
ça a été dit lors d'une réunion et qu'à
ce moment là je pensais à autre chose ou
si je ne sais pas parce que personne ne
sait mais non trêve de plaisanterie pour
le moment j'ai pas entendu parler d'un
mandat formel qui auraient été donnés
aux conseil pour intervenir dans le
cadre de ce débat citoyen sous qu'on
sait c'est que nous sommes désireux
évidemment de savoir ce qui s'y passe
est de faire le lien d'avoir
l'information sur ce qui s'y passe on
souhaite évidemment aussi que à ces gens
là on leur pose des questions qui n'ont
pas déjà été traitées 35 fois mais que
ça permettre d'apprendre des choses
nouvelles et de faire progresser la
décision publique le la question
importante est en fait c'est une autre
question qui a été envoyée c'est comment
est ce qu'on peut avoir une action
efficace dans un système tourné vers la
croissance alors vers la croissance et
d'une manière générale comment est ce
que le haut conseil pour le climat peut
amener à voir sous un angle différent
des actions dont le déterminant mais
absolument pas le climat en fait le
problème du climat aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on cherche à corriger en arrivant
après coup un certain nombre de choses
qui ne sont absolument pas décidé non
seulement qui sont pas décidé pour des
raisons climatiques mais qui sont
décidés en faisant abstraction de cette
chose là et donc vouloir corriger
derrière des décisions qui ont été
prises en faisant abstraction de ce
critère et qui donc qu'ils ont et de
décisions qui ont été prises pour
d'autres d'autres raisons c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui est un
exercice très difficile
alors je vais vous donner un exemple en
ce moment il est beaucoup question du
transport aérien la honte de prendre
l'avion les éditions d'un trajet aérien
c'est plus de 100 fois les émissions
d'un trajet en voiture quand on part en
voiture etc
et comme vous le savez probablement il
ya un débat sur la privatisation d'alépé
dans ce débat sur la privatisation de la
dp il ya notamment le fait que adp a
dans ses cartons la promesse entre
guillemets ou l'autorisation de
construire un nouveau terminal
alors petite question est ce qu'on peut
autoriser un accroissement de capacité
sur du transport aérien qui soit dit en
passant est au pétrole et restera au
pétrole pour à peu près aussi longtemps
que je vivrai pour l'essentiel jeu
pourra préciser ce point n'ont pas
longtemps tout en décidant que il serait
souhaitable de diminuer les émissions
liées au trafic aérien
c'est un peu compliqué sans platines
donc là votre décision si on pense que
donc en fait la bonne décision plus
exactement c'est de se mettre d'accord
avec soi même
dit autrement ce que va faire le haut
conseil pour le climat ce sera
probablement sa tâche la plus utile s'il
y arrive c'est d'essayer de nous
réconcilier avec nous mêmes au sens où
il faudra qu'on essaye de ne pas vouloir
à la fois le beurre et l'argent du
beurre et n'importe quelle partie de la
crémière ou du crédit
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres je vais
redonner un autre aujourd'hui quand on
décide d'une nouvelle infrastructure de
transport il y avait une note qui a été
publié il ya quelques temps augment un
an + ou - l'autorité environnementale
qui est une autorité en france qui
évalue les études d'impact sur les
infrastructures elle dit si les études
d'impact sur les projets
d'infrastructures sont à la hauteur des
enjeux environnementaux ou pas donc elle
me dit mais ne se prononce pas sur
l'opportunité de faire d'infrastructures
elle se prononce sur l'adéquation entre
l'étude d'impact et les impacts eux
mêmes prenons l exemple vous construisez
une nouvelle autoroute et tout ce que
vous regardez comme impact sur l'eau
c'est l'évacuation des toilettes sur les
aires de repos
l'autorité environnementale vous dis non
non ça va pas revoir la copie plaque te
ment personne ne dit qu'on va revoir la
copie mais on dit c'est n'importe quoi
cette autorité environnementale commence
à avoir un tout petit peu d'écho puisque
l'urbanisation du triangle d'or de
gonesse la partie qui est située entre
paris roissy sur lequel une filiale
immobilière de la groupe auchan avait
l'intention de faire un gigantesque
centre commercial le torride le permis
de construire a été invalidé par un
tribunal administratif sur la base d'un
avis de l'autorité environnementale qui
disait que les études d'impact avait été
mal faite donc ça commence ça commence
de temps en temps être un peu un peu
utile dans la décision publique
donc pour en revenir à ce que je à ce
que je disais l'autorité
environnementale a évoqué il ya pas très
longtemps la difficulté et qu'elle avait
sur les infrastructures de transport
parce que quand on veut construire une
nouvelle infrastructure de transport on
regarde ce qu'on appelle les bénéfices
socio-économiques et c'est
essentiellement le temps gagner qu'on va
chiffrer
on va dire en gros une heure productif
perdu parce que les gens se déplacent
pas assez vite ça autant 9 10 12 15 20
euros
donc le temps qu'on va gagner grâce à la
nouvelle infrastructure vous multipliez
cela par le trafic et par le nombre
d'heures économisés par personne vous
multipliez cela par la valeur du temps
et craque ça vous donne de bénéfices
socio-économiques de l'infrastructure
côté temps économisé en face il faut que
la tonne de carbone monte à des prix
monstrueux que personne n'envisage pour
que ça contrebalance ce bénéfice
résultat des courses avec la méthode
qu'on utilise c'est toujours justifiée
de construire une nouvelle
infrastructure pourvu que ça fait gagner
du temps derrière évidemment comme c'est
destiné à augmenter le trafic puisque
c'est ça qui fait gagner du temps eh
bien on dit ah zut le trafic augmente
c'est ennuyeux et les émissions
augmentent à zut c'est ennuyeux
peut-être qu'on aurait dit oui mais
comme dirait l'autre combat là à partir
du moment où la méthode elle est faite
pour valoriser le fait que le trafic
augmente pour les bénéfices
socio-économiques
on peut difficilement s'en plaindre
ensuite donc voilà une autre voilà un
exemple d'incohérences ou le haut
conseil pour le climat ne pourra rien
faire de mieux que de pointer du doigt
cette incohérence il tentait qu'on se
mette d'accord sur le fait de faire et
ensuite l'état fera exactement ce qu'il
veut de notre âme alors le candidat fera
exactement ce qu'il veut en fait notre
premier public et c'est pour ça que
notre premier rapport on va essayer de
dire des choses qui capte un peu
l'attention
notre premier public sera évidemment non
pas le premier ministre qui est
récipiendaire de notre avis et qui
s'engage à ce que le gouvernement
n'aurait compte sous six mois
mais si la presse dit autrement si notre
premier rapport capte l'attention de la
presse
on arrive à faire des gros titres
quelque part on arrive à faire quelques
20 heures etc
on aura gagné notre pari c'est à dire
qu'on s'installe dans le paysage et le
gouvernement est obligé de tenir compte
de ce qu'on raconte
si au moment où on sort notre premier
rapport et c'est pas du tout désagréable
pour rue ce que je veux dire on fait
l'objet d'un article dans rsa data news
et de deux dépêche afp que ça s'arrête
là malheureusement nous aurons
extrêmement peu de poids dans ce qui va
se passer dans la décision publique
ensuite du moins à court terme voilà
c'est parce que dans un système
démocratique il ya quelque chose qui
compte énormément
c'est la presse je vais redire une de
mes citations favorites d'un homme
politique qui était une bonne politique
qui est michel rocard
michel rocard dans ses mémoires je crois
avait écrit que premier ministre c'est
un job dans lequel on prend toutes les
deux minutes une décision sur un sujet
qu'on appelle temps de regarder et j'ai
parfaitement sa le cahier des charges ce
qui veut dire que le critère de décision
de la classe pour faire des dirigeants
ça ne peut pas être de regarder deux
sont des dossiers
ils ont juste pas le temps pour ça même
leurs conseillers techniques n'ont le
plus souvent pas le temps ou pas la
compétence ou les deux mon général pour
regarder ça et donc ce qui va compter le
plus c'est tout simplement la pression
du moment
demandons à ce qu'on arbitre dans un
sens ou dans l'autre ce qui veut dire
que l'enjeu essentiel pour le haut
conseil pour le climat je le répète
c'est l'audience qu'on aura dans la
presse donc si la presse nous fait un
large écho
on sera important si la presse ne nous
fais aucun écho pas qu'on servira à rien
parce que ça sert toujours à quelque
chose mais on a on aura un rôle beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus mineures j'ai envie
de dire dans le
dans le pays s'est pas complètement
exclu à ce stade je ne suis pas
défaitiste
qui vivra verra bien on va bien voir
dans quinze jours vous aurez les
réponses à ce stade je ne suis pas
complètement désespéré à l'idée que ce
qu'on raconte puisse avoir un tout petit
peu d'audience tout simplement alors il
ya un certain nombre d'éléments de
calendrier qui nous servent d'abord vous
avez vu que le sujet monte en pression
ici et là avec des événements dans
l'actualité le score de repères et
l'europe écologie les verts aux
européennes
rien petit couplet sur le politique plus
tard dont je vous raconterai un peu ce
que j'en pense
le lait le cas la canicule monstrueuse
en main dès qu'il vient de tuer plus de
30 personnes avec des records de
température à plus de 50 degrés les
récoltes aux états unis qui sont enfin
pardon les plantations aux états unis
dans le sens des états unis y en a ils
ont pour les mains vers ce genre déluge
et donc ils ont pris beaucoup de retard
sur la plantation de maïs et de cela et
dans un cas comme dans l'autre les états
unis fournissent quasiment un tiers des
récoltes mondiales
donc c'est quand même quelque chose qui
compte un peu enfin voilà on a on a
notre lot de mauvaises nouvelles
malheureusement qui tombe il ya la
montée en pression du manifeste
étudiants qui compte un peu aussi on va
dire dans le milieu des cadres
supérieurs et dans le milieu de
l'entreprise
on a enfin là il ya un certain nombre de
facteurs de pression qui sont en ce
moment discours de politique générale du
premier ministre dans lequel il a dit
qu'on allait faire la révolution
même si pour le moment je conserve
quelques doutes
donc voilà il ya un ya un momentum qui
paraît plutôt favorable pour que l'on
puisse espérer avoir un tout petit peu
de un tout petit peu d'audience
alors du coup je vais en profiter avant
d'attaquer le deuxième gros morceau en
fin de vie en gros morceau de cette
affaire pour finir le couplet ambiance
du moment avec quelques considérations
de avec quelques considérations de café
du commerce sur la politique le discours
de d'edouard philippe qui a été prononcé
à l'assemblée nationale et je roule à
vous en ce qui me concerne une déception
c'est une déception parce que je trouve
que je connais edouard philippe depuis
une petite dizaine d'années alors je
vais pas quelqu'un j'en vois sur la
gauche et je vois pas tous les quatre
matins
mais on a eu quelques échanges c'est lui
qui m'a fait intervenir à la commission
du développement durable de l'assemblée
nationale il ya quelques années donc la
vidéo qui traînent là sur youtube de mon
audition par la commission du
développement durable c'est à edouard
philippe que je la dois il a un fils m'a
fait venir plusieurs fois quand il était
à la communauté d'agglomération du havre
pour je secoue un peu les élus sur ces
affaires de changement climatique
donc je j'espérais que ils n'attendaient
que son heure est par exemple votre
élevés pour convaincre les tâches du
dessus c'est à dire macron que on avait
un boulevard nous la france à se lancer
de manière extrêmement ambitieuse dans
cette histoire de décarbonation
d'économie je l'espérais d'autant plus
qu'on voit monter la société civile je
trouve de façon significative sur ce
sujet encore une fois le vote élevées en
est une en est une conséquence mais pas
que pour moi qui prenne mes guêtres dans
les entreprises depuis maintenant 20 ans
je vais pas dire qu'elles sont prêtes à
faire la révolution dans les monts ordre
de grandeur mais on arrive à obtenir
aujourd'hui des résultats qui était
totalement impensable il ya seulement
trois ou quatre ans donc les choses sont
en train d'évoluer et je trouve que
c'est ça me paraissait comment dire
jouable que il ya une grande ambition
parieurs on a quand même besoin dans ce
pays pour susciter l'adhésion d'autres
choses que des comptes d'apothicaire sur
le déficit budgétaire parce que les
comptes d'apothicaire son déficit
budgétaire
et pas une personne dans ce pays que ça
équipe vraiment c'est un moyen c'est
absolument pas une fin personne personne
bon dans ce pays qui a un doute passion
professionnelle le dit je vais choisir
un métier juste parce que ça me permet
de boucler mes fins de mois c'est une
contrainte boucler ses fins de mois
mais c'est c'est pas une passion
professionnelle bon donc là c'est pareil
s'occuper du déficit budgétaire ces
contraintes
c'est pas une passion professionnelle
donc il manque un grand projet dans ce
pays on a quand même la possibilité de
le faire valoir dans le monde dans
lequel on vit la france garde quand même
un peu de l'audience va tout un tas
davantage assister enfin voilà donc je
m'attendais à ce que on se dit bon ok
wake up call on s'y colle et qu'est ce
qu'on entend on entend qu'il y aura pas
de plastique à usage unique dans
l'administration bon ça c'est bien 17
une partie du tout c'est pas le tout on
entend qu'on va fermer fessenheim
vous savez tous que j'en pense en fait
une connerie parce que plus généralement
s'occuper de fermer du nucléaire dans
notre pays est une connerie on explique
qu'on va faire de l'éolien offshore très
bien 25 milliards d'euros ont mis dans
les éoliennes offshore
c'est une connerie au sens de avec ses
25 milliards d'euros
je vais alimenter l'industrie étrangères
pour partie donc l'identité 25 milliards
vont aller nourrir les allemands et les
chinois et des danois la déficit
commercial étant ce qu il s était pas la
peine d'en rajouter
ça ne va rien changer sur le co2 et
comme on ne peut pas remplacer du nom
pilotable enfin du pilotable par
longtemps du nom pilotable dit autrement
avec un mode non pilotable qu'est
l'éolien je ne peux pas supprimer des
capacités pilotable c'est à dire celle
où j'ai de l'électricité quand je veux
des exemples allemands et espagnols le
montre très bien ça fait juste un peu
baissé le facteur de charge du nucléaire
donc ça augmente le risque nucléaire
donc pas de co2 gagné augmentation des
importations donc destruction de
l'emploi et diminution de la sûreté
nucléaire avec 25 milliards d'euros j'ai
mieux à faire et dans les choses qui me
paraissent plus pertinentes à faire et
dont je vais vous livrer un petit secret
j'ai suggéré ça à edouard philippe
le jour de l'installation du haut
conseil pour le climat le 27 novembre
dernier
du ludique avec ses 25 milliards d'euros
on pourrait payer 6000 euros de prime 1
à chaque ménage français chauffées au
fioul
ils sont 4 millions donc si vide au
rocket millions ça fait 24 milliards sur
le prix d orléans shore pour supprimer
la totalité du fioul dans notre pays en
remplaçant dans une pompe à chaleur
comme ils trouvent que par ailleurs les
gens chauffer au fioul et les gilets
jaunes à mon avis se recouvrent assez
largement
je pense que ça c'était quelque chose
qui n'y était gagnant sur tous les
tableaux
1 ça permet d'éviter 15 % du pétrole
qu'on apporte c'est à dire les bonnes
années et quasiment 10 milliards d'euros
les mauvaises 5 ça permettait d'éviter
en gros 10 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre du pays est comme ça
permet d'éviter des importations ça crée
de l'emploi avec le même argent c'est à
dire que j'utilise pas plus d'argent que
vos impôts parce que ces 25 milliards
d'euros ils vont sortir de vos poches
comme des hyènes avec essentiellement
des taxes sur les carburants
parce que maintenant c'est les taxes sur
les carburants qui finance le compte
d'affectation spéciale de la transition
énergétique
donc ce le fait qu' edouard philippe
dans son discours soit revenu sur le
développement de l'éolien offshore qui
est un truc dans notre pays qui ne sert
à rien je ne dirais pas ça en pologne
je ne dirais pas ça au maroc je ne
dirais pas ça il ya plein de pays où je
ne dirais pas ça évidemment je parle
bien du cas français et est dit par
ailleurs qu'il fallait continuer à
planter des banderilles dans le dos du
nucléaire alors que on a une industrie
nucléaire qui fonctionne et 2000 200
gigawatts de centrales à charbon a
supprimé dans le monde
je suis je voulais vous assez déçu je me
demande dans quelle mesure il faut pas
commencer à faire l'éducation écolo de
marion maréchal qui doit être dans les
starting blocks pour remplacer l'actuel
occupant de l'elysée
et pour finir sur cette veine quand on
voit qu en italie l'extrême droite et
d'extrême gauche se sont alliés pour
remporter la présidence
je ne fais pas partie des gens qui
pensent que jamais à tout jamais dans ce
pays on n'aura pas quelque chose de
bizarre arrivant au pouvoir avant que je
ne parte du tout rassuré sur cette
affaire-là donc le don donc voilà donc
je pense que le
ce discours de politique générale montre
qu'il ya encore énormément de boulot
pour arriver à quelque chose qui soit
cohérent au niveau de ce pays je suis un
peu déçu est-ce que du coup le vote eux
élevés il change quelque chose bah oui
je pense que justement il a fait ce
discours de politique générale afin de
discours de politique générale dans
lequel on a dit qu'on allait accélérer
sur l'éolien et la baisse du nucléaire
et moi j'y vois malheureusement
essentiellement une manoeuvre électorale
ce qu'il faut ramasser le vote des
antinucléaires aux prochaines
municipales et donc on se positionne
pour le rattraper c'est ce que je
comprends donc je comprends que
l'énergie restent dans la tête de notre
président quelque chose qui est un enjeu
électoral déconnecté de la totalité du
monde qui nous entoure
c'est comme ça que je lis ce qui vient
de se passer
voilà alors maintenant on va parler de
choses qui n'ont strictement rien à voir
une question a été posée beaucoup
d'entre nous avons un peu d'épargnants
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'efficace
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
alors c'est une excellente question pour
faire un peu le lèche cul comme dans les
émissions américaines en cinq ans les
émissions américaines quand on veut se
mettre le journaliste qui est en général
quand on veut gagner un peu de temps où
ce match et pas qui dans la poche on
commence par dire ça c'est une
excellente question
il ya alors il ya deux manières de
répondre à cette question
la première c'est on peut transformer
cette épargne en patrimoine personnel
on vous pouvez par exemple acheter un
bout de forêt donc c'est toujours un
placement et à ce moment vous assure que
vous n'avez pas des obligations des
actions s'est pas liquide beaucoup moins
liquides mais c'est l'emplacement ces
départs ne s'avouera porte un petit
quelque chose et puis ça a une valeur
patrimoniale dont vous pouvez sur
laquelle vous pouvez être plus rassurés
sur si les arbres cramer sauf que sur
laquelle vous pouvez être plus rassuré
que si vous avez des obligations de
l'état italien
petit détour pour ceux d'entre vous qui
n'ont pas assisté aux excellente
présentation des ateliers du shift sur
cette question l'essentiel de l'épargné
financière des français c'est de
l'assurance-vie et l'essentiel de
l'assurance vie ce sont des obligations
d'état
donc en gros quand vous avez de
l'assurance vie vous avez pour
l'essentiel des obligations françaises
italiennes allemandes espagnoles
les allemandes il vaut mieux pas en
avoir trop aujourd'hui parce que son un
rendement négatif
les obligations d'état tu prends est
évidemment plus le rendement est élevé
plus on se dit que l'état pourrait bien
faire défaut sur sa dette ce qui lie à
ce qui est arrivé à un certain nombre de
fois deux pays et qui à mon avis se
renouvellera donc vous pouvez arbitré en
faveur d'une épargne j'ai envie de dire
privé au sens où c'est pas liquide pour
acheter de l'immobilier etc
si vous voulez faire quelque chose
d'utile pour changement climatique alors
vous avez un sous-ensemble de cette
épargne qui peut il correspondre
alors je vais vous donner quelques
exemples le premier comme je le disais
c'est d'acheter de la forêt et de faire
en sorte que cette forêt séquestre le
maximum de carbone possible vous pouvez
acheter des terres vous avez des
associations qui recueille de les
parrains comme ça à faire de lien si ma
mémoire est bonne
et à ce moment votre épargne sert à
permettre à des agriculteurs de
s'installer avec un cahier des charges
qui lui comporte des éléments qui sont
bons pour le changement climatique
puisque il essaye de faire des choses
avec moins d'intrants de synthèse qui
est un des gros contributeurs les
engrais azotés de synthèse c'est un gros
contributeur au changement climatique
puisque c'est fait avec du craquage du
métal c'est là c'est la chimie de
l'ammoniac il y en a là dedans qui
essaye de faire de la traction animale
plutôt que de la traction motorisés qui
a fabriqué des gens qui les circuits
courts des amap en fin de droits dont
vous avez un
vous avez là dedans des gens qui
essayent de faire des choses on va dire
avec notamment une partie empreinte
carbone a baissé vous pouvez l'investir
dans des entreprises tout à fait ils
liquident aussi mais qui ont besoin de
çà de là ça va souvent être du capital
de proximité j'ai envie de dire vous
avez quelqu'un qui veut se lancer qui
veut faire un truc qui est utile j'en
sais rien il va être publiée par exemple
et installer des pompes à chaleur il
veut être et à ce moment c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est utile pour le
changement climatique voilà que vous
avez vous avez d investissement de cette
nature qui peuvent être qu'ils peuvent
être pertinents
après vous pouvez souhaiter rester dans
des choses qui sont entre guillemets
plus classique donc vous allez voir
votre banquier ou lui dit ah je voudrais
avoir mieux que ce que j'ai aujourd'hui
et alors là on va tomber dans un
problème qui est la définition de bio
parce que aujourd'hui de l'epargne dont
le caractère principal soit que saab est
l'empreinte carbone du du de l'objet
dans lequel vous investissez ça n'existe
pas ce que vous avez aujourd'hui afin
que ça n'existe quasiment pas je vais
préciser puisque vous avez quelques
exceptions mais ça n'existe quasiment
pas ce que vous avez aujourd'hui c'est
énormément d'investissement qui sont
labellisés et sr c'est à dire
investissement socialement responsable
sauf que l'investissement socialement
responsable choisie un certain nombre
d'objectifs parmi les dix sept objectifs
du développement durable des nations
unies qui se marchent sur les pieds les
uns les autres parce que dans ces
objectifs vous avez dit mié la pauvreté
par exemple sauf que diminuer la
pauvreté tout le monde l'entend comme je
vais augmenter les revenus des pauvres
je pas toucher aux revenus des riches
mais je vais augmenter les revenus des
pauvres
pardon je fais une parenthèse dans la
parenthèse la pauvreté pour ceux d'entre
vous qui ne le savent pas ça a une
définition mathématiques
ça se définit comme la fraction de la
population qui gagnent moins d'un
certain pourcentage du revenu médian de
mémoire 50 ou 70 % je ne sais plus mais
temps 50 % il s'est même si c'est faux
c'est pour illustrer le phénomène
donc ça veut dire que vous avez une
distribution qui ressemble comme toute
distribution en gros ciel là où à peu
près et donc tous les gens qui sont
situés à gauche de 50% de la mégane et
bien c'est des gens donc ce qui sépare
les 50% qui gagne le plus de 50% qui
viennent le moins
eh bien à ces gens là sont considérés
comme pour voir alors une première
manière de supprimer la pauvreté c'est
de resserrer la distribution si vous
avez une distribution plus resserré que
l'homme était un peu et allez vous la
resserrer et bien à ce moment vous avez
une plus faible proportion des gens qui
sont situés à gauche de 50% des revenus
donc égalisé les revenus c'est une
manière de diminuer la pauvreté mais
égaliser les revenus ça vous suppriment
les bas revenus mais ça vous suppriment
aussi des hauts revenus or ça les hauts
revenus sont en général proche des
cercles du pouvoir ils sont assez peu
d'accord pour qu'on les tombes au profit
de la collectivité
la deuxième manière de supprimer la
pauvreté c'est carrément d
placez le revenu médian est en lui des
pauvres mais ça suppose de tondre encore
plus les riches qui sont encore moins
d'accord enfin où les riches ou les
classes moyennes supérieures qui sont
encore moins d'accord donc supprimer la
pauvreté tout le monde l'entend comme je
vais augmenter les bas revenus sans
toucher aux hauts revenus
sauf que si vous faites ça vous
augmenter la production économique dont
vous augmentez la transformation de
l'environnement dont vous augmentez
toutes les tous les autres envers devant
dans les objectifs du développement
durable demande qu'on se passe donc
faire un feuillet serre c'est très
simple ça peut être un fonds dans lequel
vous dites je m'occupais de la pauvreté
et je regarde pas le reste crac scellier
serre vous pouvez avoir un fonds dans
lequel vous dites je vais m'occuper de
la pauvreté je vais m'occuper de l'accès
à l'éducation et je vais m'occuper du
droit des femmes tout ça c'est dans les
objectifs du développement durable je me
contrefous l'impact sur le climat et 4
cia sert donc si vous voulez investir
dans quelque chose qu'ils fassent
nécessairement du bien pour le climat
même si ça fait aussi du bien à tout un
tas d'autres trucs qui sont tout à fait
légitimes et bien vous n'avez pas
aujourd'hui de méthode qui vous
garantissent ce genre de choses
alors vous avez des choses qui sont en
approche est du reste pour faire un tout
petit peu de pub au sein de carbone 4
nous avons une filiale qui vend une
méthode qui est totalement concentré sur
l'aspect clients donc qui est totalement
concentré sur le fait d'être plus bas
carbone que la moyenne ou d'avoir une
activité qui est alignée entre
guillemets avec un monde qui
respecterait les deux degrés mais cette
méthode
beaucoup de nos clients il incorpore
pour noter leurs portefeuilles
mais ils ne font pas de produits
financiers qui sont totalement articulé
là dessus à une exception près nous
avons comme client euronext qui nous
achètent les données pour faire un
indice qui est totalement orientée sur
l'aspect climat et pas sur le reste
alors dont par ailleurs on peut discuter
la composition la performance et c est
le fait que ce soit suffisant pour
sauver le monde mais en attendant c'est
un produit qui est purement climat voilà
mais y en a pas beaucoup
donc si vous êtes joueur et que vous
aimez bien les achats d'actions et bien
vous pouvez miser sur cet indice vendus
par onex donc il ya des fonds qui sont
bnp en particulier en ferrain
c'est factuel parce que j'aime bien bnp
c'est jusqu'à lisant points donc qui est
calée sur cet indice
sinon vous avez très peu de produits qui
sont encore une fois structuré
totalement climat voilà donc s'y est ce
que ça va changer à l'avenir on pourrait
compléter la question par ça alors vous
avez actuellement à la commission
européenne une discussion qui est en
cours sur le green freinage parce que
les financiers aiment bien parler de
bruyne et du rs10 aime bien parler de
green parce que sallèles ça leur laisse
justement la latitude de jouer sur
plusieurs critères et donc de tomber ray
quelque part et s'ils sont pas très bon
sur un critère se disent pas grave on se
rattrape sur un autre et cette
discussion en cours doit doit redéfinir
finalement ce que c'est que la farine et
du coup d'ici quelques années
vous aurez des produits qui seront verts
au sens ils cochent les cases qui sont
recommandés par la commission européenne
donc ils sont édictées par la commission
européenne en disant ça c'est derrière
ça c'est pas vert or malheureusement ça
suffira pas non plus pour faire quelque
chose qui soit propre
sur le plan du pinard parce que pour le
moment on se dirige vers une méthode qui
dit ce qui est vert c'est un objet vous
avez deux manières de prendre le
problème vous pouvez dire ce qui est
vert c'est ce qui fait baisser les
émissions
donc si par exemple je vais de la
capture et séquestration sur une
centrale à charbon
c'est d'ailleurs avant les mettait en
avant et après les mais beaucoup moins
si je passe une centrale à charbon au
gaz ou au nucléaire sévère puisque ça et
mettaient beaucoup ça et mais beaucoup
moins ou si je suis un vendeur de
grosses voitures et que je me mets avant
des petites voitures à la place des
grosses voitures que mes clients avaient
avancés l'air puisque ça va être les
émissions ça c'est une c'est une manière
de voir les choses est soit dit en
passant c'est la mienne la deuxième
manière de voir les choses c'est de dire
une voiture électrique c'est vers quelle
que soit la manière de produire
d'électricité jeune homme l'objet quelle
l'électricité quelle que soit la taille
de la voiture et son poids donc ce même
si elle fait deux tonnes et que j'ai une
batterie monstrueuse dedans sachant que
les émissions de fabrication de la
batterie c'est la moitié des émissions
fabrication de l'ensemble c'est plus que
les émissions fabrication du reste de la
voiture est bien ainsi j'ai une grosse
voiture électrique ce programme
en chine c'est à dire quand même parce
qu'une voiture électrique c'est vers une
éolienne c'est l'air que je l'installé
au maroc pour remplacer du charbon ou en
france pour remplacer du nucléaire je
m'en fous sévère et c'est donc on a une
borne de recharge c'est d'ailleurs et
c'est donc la commission européenne
aujourd'hui elle est partie plutôt sur
la deuxième voie ce qui à mon avis est
une erreur alors elle est partie sur
cette voie parce que l'essentiel des
experts qui sont en train de dire voilà
comment il faudrait faire sont par
ailleurs des gens qui sont juges et
parties puisqu'il travaille dans des
établissements financiers
donc ils sont compliqués jusqu'à l'os
puisque évidemment ils vont choisir un
système qui les arrangent et qui limite
la quantité d'efforts qui vont devoir
mettre pour savoir si ces verrous pas
parce que si on a besoin à chaque fois
d'embaucher un quart 24 quelconque pour
savoir si sévère ou pas c'est à dire si
après actions les émissions ont baissé
évidemment ça limite plus l'action mais
ça coûte plus cher que si vous dites une
éolienne c'est vers quoi qu'il arrive à
ce moment vous avez besoin de personne
il ya câble mesurer la quantité d'argent
que les vides dans et on considère que
ça va bien donc c'est donc encore une
fois comme c'est essentiellement des
financiers qui sont hors de la table ils
font ce que je ferai à leur place c'est
à dire adopter le système qui dans
simplifie dali et avant qu'on se rende
compte que on avait fait ce qu'il
fallait pas ils seront loin
voilà c'est comme ça que beaucoup de
gens voilà donc pour en revenir à la
question qui est si on veut faire
quelque chose d'utile pour le climat
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec son avec
son épargne et bien c'est c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué malheureusement que que
la réponse qui aurait été la réponse la
plus sympathique qui est et voilà allez
la coller ici ou aller la colle est là
et c'est extrêmement simple et même des
gens qui font du financement dits
éthiques ou du financement citoyens ou
du financement collectif peuvent faire
les erreurs que je viens d'évoquer par
exemple vous avez en france des
organismes qui font de l'epargne
citoyenneté etc et qui font du panneau
solaire
c'est à dire un truc qui est peut-être
très bien pour des tas d'autres raisons
que le climat mais qui n'est sûrement
pas quelque chose qui est pertinent que
le climat voilà donc vous n'avez pas
aujourd'hui encore une fois
deux labels et de méthodes qui
permettent de flécher les
investissements de façon orthodoxe là
dessus alors une question qui n'a
strictement rien à voir mais que j'ai
bien aimé qui est au niveau municipal
quels sont les leviers de décarbonation
accessible et assez rapidement pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont lu le manifeste du
shift pour décarbonés l'europe avant les
dernières élections présidentielles
on avait mis en annexe à ce manifeste
neuf propositions qui représentait le
gros de l'effort qui nous semble à faire
en europe à partir du moment où on veut
s'attaquer au problème quelque part on
pourrait refaire ses propositions au
niveau municipal et on se rendrait
compte que ce qu'une collectivité peut
faire est de deux ordres
le premier c'est de ne pas faire
accroître le problème donc de ne pas
faire accroître le problème c'est par
exemple d'arrêter de délivrer les permis
de construire dans des logements qu'ils
soient accessibles qu'en voiture ça
accroît le problème c'est d'arrêter de
délivrer des permis de construire qui
conduisent à l'artificialisation des
sols
c'est donc il ya un certain nombre de
choses parce que ça va aller vite la
séquestration de carbone ça augmente les
prêtres de ruissellement en cas de pluie
ça augmente le besoin en infrastructures
de transport derrière phase avec les
besoins d'infrastructures de toute
nature à venir si on est plus nombreux à
associer un sujet on en parlera tout à
l'heure c'est un vrai sujet si la
démographie michel rocard l'avait dit en
son temps il avait dit la france ne peut
pas accueillir toute la misère du monde
alors c'était une autre manière de dire
on peut pas accueillir autant de gens
qu'on veut on a quand même un problème
sur cette planète qui est que la planète
fait treize mille kilomètres de diamètre
que c'était le cas quand on était un
milliard sur terre que c'était le cas
quand on monte mais quand on était 5
millions sur terre il ya très longtemps
et que c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
et que ça sera pas différent demain et
que la quantité de gens qui vont partir
avec elon musk et ses rails de cocaïne
sur la lune c'est pas sûr qu'il y en ait
beaucoup
donc on a par ailleurs un problème
démographique qu'on doit gérer qu'on
doit gérer à l'échelon international et
qu'on voit aussi gérer à l'échelon
national parce que même en france ne
peut pas augmenter indéfiniment la
population sans contrepartie qui feront
qu'un jour la population baissera sans
trop que ce soit agréable sur ce sera ça
sera un peu plus désagréable que si ça
se faisait naturellement le don qu'il ya
un sujet qui est ne pas laisser pour les
vampires et c'est souvent quelque chose
auquel on pense pas en premier c'est
évidemment quelque chose d'important
dans les collectivités locales
on a un sujet alors que les maires sont
aujourd'hui pousser à l'exact inverse
si vous avez une commune avec plus
d'habitants vont peser plus dans les
intercommunalités
si vous avez une commune avec plus
d'habitants vous avez plusieurs recettes
fiscales si vous avez une commune avec +
habitants vous peser plus dans le
paysage politique mon écoute plus le
maire de lyon que le maire de
trifouillis les trois canards donc vous
avez aujourd'hui quelque part une course
à la taille qui est pas une obsession
mais qui est une tendance naturelle de
tout élu qui va donc avoir envie
d'accorder des permis de construire à
tire larigot à chaque fois qu on lui
demande ce qu'il fait dire s'il fait
dire soit dit en passant que je me
demande dans quelle mesure il ne serait
pas aujourd'hui pertinent de retirer le
permis cancer au maire ou à tout le
moins d'avoir un droit de veto de l'état
sur sur base du respect d'un certain
nombre de schémas d'aménagement qui sont
importants à respecter et qui doivent
être respectées popian donc au niveau
des élus donc je le redis premier
problème ne pas laisser pour les
vampires et après la question dépend
aussi énormément de la ville si vous
avez une ville comme paris par exemple
qui est extrêmement dépendante du
tourisme international est bien le bilan
carbone de paris l'avion m'a-t-on dit
alors j'ai pas fait le calcul mais
l'avion représente un tiers du total
ce n'est pas un tiers c'est 15 ou 20 de
toute façon ça sera quelque chose de
très significatif
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire à paris
pour diminuer l'empreinte carbone de
l'aviation et bien à part prier rien
parce que vous ne fabriquez pas d'avion
donc vous pouvez éventuellement essayer
de faire de la retape sur paris plutôt
auprès des allemands des anglais des
italiens et des provinciaux qu'auprès
des japonais et des chinois pour
complètement convaincu qu'aujourd'hui en
face pâle inverse en juger quand on va
là dedans paris par la quantité de
touristes chinois qui s'y balade
le mais à part ça je veux dire il n'y a
pas grand chose à faire
la renonciation à cette partie là de
l'empreinte carbone serait une
renonciation aux recettes touristiques
correspondante
je suis pas complètement sûr que madame
hidalgo on est très envie que quel que
soit son discours par ailleurs si vous
êtes dans une toute petite commune
rurale du gers
eh bien il est évident que l'équation se
présente pas du tout de la même manière
parce que vous avez par exemple et
d'activités agricoles très importantes
alors qu'à paris à part les lignes de la
butte montmartre et éventuellement
quelques légumes qu'on fait pousser dans
quelques potager bien planqué il ya
quand même pas grand chose donc vous
avez un paysage de départ qui n'est pas
du tout le même
mais là encore l'élu il a deux fonctions
il a une fonction de réglementation des
activités qui se trouvent sur son sol et
puis par ailleurs petite île là et
notamment encore une fois bien
l'autorisation majeur qui a permis de
construire et puis il a un rôle de
gestion de son patrimoine propre et des
infrastructures qui le propose à ses
concitoyens donc sur les infrastructures
il ya toute une réflexion après je vais
commencer à sortir des évidences il ya
toute une réflexion à avoir sur la place
de la voiture versus la place des modes
partager ou actifs donc partager ces bus
train covoiturage actifs cédés l'eau
marche à pied avec aujourd'hui à votre
briquet vélo électrique vos d'actifs
mais insisté et puis il ya un autre un
autre chose une autre chose qui est
évidente c'est le patrimoine immobilier
donc là il ya le sien propre plus celui
de ses administrés alors sur les
administrés par exemple comme une riche
pourraient très bien donner des coups de
pouce pour l'isolation des bâtiments ou
obligé vous savez qu'il ya un certain
nombre de communes où le ravalement et
obligatoire je crois que c'est une règle
municipal je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
vrai dans toutes les communes je pense
que le ravalement fois je vais agir donc
encore ici j utilise mais il me semble
que le ravalement et quelque chose qui
était dicté par la mairie
la mairie pourrait très bien obligés à
l'isolation par l'extérieur lors du
ravalement partout il n'y a pas de
caractère architectural donc vous avez à
paris par exemple des boules des
immeubles haussmanniens sur lesquels la
façade sur rue
ça va être difficile par contre la
façade sur cour il ya un certain nombre
de cas de figure où elle n'a pas de
caractère architectural vous avez après
plein d'immeubles modernes n'ont pas de
caractère architectural voilà c'est très
simple de dire au moment du ravalement
par l'extérieur caps obligations
isolation par l'extérieur ça c'est de la
compétence du maire par exemple enfin
vous a peut être de la compétence du
maire le berck décidé d'allouer des
moyens à l'information et aux fêtes de
presser ses administrés pour qu'il fasse
des choses il ya d'autres domaines dans
lequel il ne fait donc le maire a
également comme je disais tout à l'heure
la compétence sur les règles de
circulation
donc il peut affecter l'espace de
stationnement qui est un gros
déterminant du fait que les gens aient
une voiture ou pas il peut affecter
l'occupation de l'espace sur la voirie
c'est au niveau local que se décide la
gestion des transports en commun c'est
au niveau local que se décide également
une partie des implantations d'activités
là où sera par exemple l'école ici
plutôt que là donc l'élu local
il a un pouvoir certain à mon avis il a
aujourd'hui un problème qui est le même
que le problème politique au niveau
national c'est à dire qu'il ne sait pas
faire la pédagogie du problème je ne
crois pas que beaucoup de maires sache
expliquer ce que c'est que le changement
climatique
en quoi ça va chier des bulles carré si
jamais on s'en occupe pas sérieusement
en quoi de toute façon on va devoir
s'adapter à celui qui est déjà embarqué
et en quoi c'est de son devoir de
pousser ses concitoyens à s'en occuper
et que ya les moyens de faire des choses
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ya très très
peu d'élus locaux qui ont les bases
techniques qui permettent de faire la
pédagogie du problème ce qui est un vrai
sujet est il à la deuxième deuxième
sujet qui est le consentement affaire où
le consentement à payer ou le
consentement à l'effort des gens qui
habitent sur sa commune mais encore une
fois il a quand même il a il ya quand
même une barge est aujourd'hui les élus
locaux sont très avance en ordre
dispersé donc il y en a qui font des
choses qui sont extrêmement intéressante
il y en a qui font des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus anecdotique
si j'oubliais une chose importante c'est
qu'elle locale il a le pouvoir
d'organiser la distribution à travers
les surfaces qui d'elle ou au commerce à
travers les permis de construire donc ça
c'est aussi quelque chose qui est
absolument majeur selon vous décidez de
faire que des places de marché ouverte
le matin ouverte le soir etc ou que vous
décidez de faire que des grandes
surfaces en périphérie
c'est évident que vous structurez une
bonne partie de l'approvisionnement
local sur les produits sur les produits
agricoles et que vous structurez une
partie de l'économie locale de façon un
peu un peu différente il a également le
pouvoir sur la restauration scolaire et
en fait ça ça peut être une pompe
d'amorçage pour justement une partie des
circuits courts et des activités
agricoles
alors encore une fois c'est plus facile
d'avoir des circuits courts quand vous
êtes dans un village du gers que quand
vous êtes à paris parce que c'est de
mémoire villes de france serait capable
de nourrir 6 % des franciliens
même si on mange peu de viande admettre
sa place à 12
c'est quand même pas 100 % donc c'est
plus facile de commencer à faire que du
circuit court quand vous êtes dans une
commune au milieu d'un paysage agricole
que quand vous êtes dans une commune
dans une très grande île alors après
j'ai un gros paquet de questions sur la
décroissance sa décroissance alors est
ce qu'on peut avoir mon avis sur la
décroissance comme dynamique d'avenir
la réponse il n'ya aucun avenir à la
décroissance comme dynamique
il y a un avenir à la décroissance comme
contrainte
il n'y a pas d'avenir à la décroissance
comme dynamique alors je vais essayer de
donner un exemple imaginons parce que
c'est très bon pour le physique est très
bon pour le mental que je travaille au
quatrième étage d'un immeuble et que au
lieu de prendre l'ascenseur je prenne
les escaliers parce que je me dis comme
ça ça peut faire un peu d'exercice et
que les escaliers c'est sympa et puis on
est toujours susceptible
d'y croiser son voisin et dire bonjour
avec un air plus gêné moins gêné par
donc dans l'ascenseur donc je prends les
escaliers et alors je suis de plus en
plus performants oui je commence à
travailler à 20 ans je travaille tout et
puis je monte les escaliers je
m'entraîne ont-ils escaliers en un temps
de plus en plus brefs et je me dis ce
qui va être l'indicateur cardinal de mon
bonheur c'est le temps que je mets à
monter les escaliers alors pendant dix
ans c'est à l'aube lit je monte chaque
jour les escaliers donnant plus vite
et puis ma carcasse vieilli cette
cochonnerie quand ça se fatiguer et donc
arrive un jour où à chaque fois que je
vais mesurer le temps que je vais mettre
à monter ces fichus d'escalier le temps
deviendra inférieure à un supérieur
pardon à ceux qu'ils étaient la veille
donc je suis toujours capable de mesurer
le temps que je mets à monter les
escaliers
mais si je le garde comme indicateur
cardinal de mon bonheur je vais me
mettre à déprimer tous les quatre matins
alors cette petite parabole est là pour
faire comprendre que le pib c'est
exactement pareil
c'est à dire comme ça fait deux siècles
que le pib augmente et qu'on considère
que le fait qu'il augmente c'est
l'indicateur cardinal de du progrès que
nous effectuerons je ne crois pas une
seconde que l'on puisse vendre la
décroissance comme projet de société
c'est à dire dire à partir de maintenant
mon objectif c'est de faire baisser le
pib et pluie d'aces vite plus je suis
heureux je n'y crois pas une seconde je
crois que c'est impossible
par contre ce que je crois et c'est lié
à quelque chose que je vais évoquer plus
tard sur l'énergie c'est que le pib de
toute façon ne peut pas croître
indéfiniment alors même si la théorie
économique dans sa grande sagesse n'a
jamais prévu ce qui permettrait de dire
à 72 mille milliards de dollars dans le
monde le pib s'arrête d'augmenter c'est
pas écrit dans la théorie économique ça
alors que la théorie physique qu'elle
vous dit vous faites un trou dans la
terre
il vise à ressortir de l'autre côté il
faut une mèche qui résiste aux
intempéries tueur du centre de la terre
mais peu importe qu'on va imaginer qu'on
l'a et bien quand votre mais ça fait
treize mille kilomètres sous terre elle
peut pas rester sous terre est obligé de
ressortir
et bien dans la théorie économique qui a
pas un pays d atteinte elle valeur ils
s'arrêtent d'augmenter donc on a inventé
un système qui est en théorie est limité
et ça fait des siècles qu'on se dit plus
a augment ce foutu pib mais on se porte
donc c'est impossible de revenir là
dessus par contre comme je crois moi
dans ma vision du monde qu' il ya des
facteurs limitants au pib qui ne sont
pas juste la quantité de bons hommes et
capital humain mais aussi les ressources
disponibles pour la transformation et la
capacité de les transformer c'est à dire
l'énergie
mon avis est du reste les analyses que
j'effectue depuis dix ans qui sont
matérialisés par quelques courbes que
certains d'entre vous connaissent c'est
que l'économie au premier ordre répond à
la quantité d'énergie qu'on met dans le
système alors pourquoi est ce que c'est
le cas parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
produisent des machines toute la
production dans le monde et effectuer de
l'ère des machines vêtements la chemise
que je porte sur moi a été faite par une
machine l'ordinateur qui sert à
communiquer avec vous et essai par des
machines la table sur lequel il est
posée a été fait par des machines
ça a été amenée chez moi par une machine
c'est à dire en l'occurrence une voiture
parce que je les croise un camion pour
ça c'était passé gros c'est enfin voila
je parle dans un micro qui a été fait
par des machines et des machines ont
fait tous les composants qui permet au
signal d' arriver jusqu'à chez vous puis
tout à l'heure vous allez manger en
utilisant une machine c'est à dire une
cuisinière sortir la nourriture d'une
autre machine frigo cette nourriture
aurait été acheminée jusqu'aux chez vous
par des camions et machines donc on vit
dans un monde de machines tout ce qu'on
utilise ces des machines toute la
production c'est des machines et des
machines pour fonctionner elles ont
besoin d'énergie c'est malheureusement
la loi de conservation d'énergie qu'il
impose donc dis moi combien tu consommes
d'énergie je te dirai combien tu fais
fonctionner de machines dont je te dirai
combien tu produis c'est à peu près
aussi simple que ça du coup dans ma
vision du monde où le pib est limitée
par la quantité d'énergie dont on
dispose
le pib va de toute façon blessé dans une
transition bas carbone
il va de toute façon baissé d'une
transition dakaroise alors il va baisser
soit de façon organisée
c'est à dire qu'on décide de baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à la
vitesse nécessaire pour éviter que ça
soit la barbarie partout rue du
changement climatique et à ce moment il
faut baisser les émissions dans le monde
2 4% par an
en france c'est à peu près pareil ce qui
veut dire que vous baissez la quantité
d'énergie fossile de 4% par an et tous
les calculs que j'ai fait dans tous les
sens montre que jamais l'éolien et le
solaire et même en rajoutant le
nucléaire ne permettrait de compenser le
déclin de 4% par an de l'énergie fossile
qu'on utilise parce que 80% de l'énergie
qui déclinent de 4% par an ça ne peut
pas être compensée par l'augmentation du
reste qui en plus a besoin d'énergie
fossile et surtout l'éolien et le
solaire beaucoup moins nucléaire pour
fonctionner vous avez 100 fois plus de
métal par kilowattheure produit dans un
kilowattheure solaire ou même éolien
c'est pas les mêmes méthodes que dans un
kilowatt heure nucléaire au gaz ou
charbon centre plus de métal dont vous
avez besoin de plein d'énergie pour
extraire le métal de la mine pour faire
fonctionner le système
aujourd'hui l'éolien c'est pas cher
parce que on a plein d'énergie fossile
dans les engins de mines pour sortir
enfin de métaux mais si on avait que des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes pour
sortir les bateaux de la mine et faire
la métallurgie ah bon c'est pas sûr que
ça resterait au même prix donc le donc
le le système dans lequel on vit qui est
un monde de machines costume de superman
à tous dans un approvisionnement
énergétique qui se contracte et c'est ça
qu'on a si on baisse les émissions
chaque année on a le pib qui baisse ça
veut donc dire que la baisse du pib
c'est pas un projet en tant que tel
parce que pour reprendre parallèle de
l'escalier tout à l'heure c'est
invendable ans quand elle par contre je
pense que c'est un codicille inexorable
de la transition bas carbone
vous avez bien voici on si c'est si ça
veut dire que le pib baisse faisons pas
la transition bas carbone alors là j'ai
malheureusement une mauvaise nouvelle
c'est qu'on a une voiture balai la
voiture balai c'est que de toute façon
qu'on le veuille ou pas
l'approvisionnement énergétique finira
par baisser finira par baisser parce que
quand vous avez besoin de 100 millions
d'années en ordre de grandeur pour faire
du pétrole du gaz ou du charbon ça se
renouvelle pas et donc vous pouvez pas
avoir un approvisionnement à définir en
croissance en provenance d'un stock de
départ qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes
de ce fait la voiture balai va
s'appliquer quand est ce que la voiture
balai s'applique en europe
maintenant c'est ça la bonne nouvelle
elle s'applique entre regarder les
chiffres sur la consommation énergétique
en europe ça décroît depuis 2006 et soit
dit en passant
l'europe est la seule zone n'est pas
encore regardé les chiffres en détail
mais je sais que c'est ça le résultat
l'europe est la seule zone qui de 2017 à
2018 a vu son approvisionnement
énergétique recommencé à baisser
nous sommes cernés par des zones en
déclin sur toutes les grandes énergies
fossiles que nous utilisons le charbon
qui est une énergie domestique passe qui
se transporte près mal malgré le fait
qu'ils aient quelques échanges
internationaux
l'europe est en déclin de production
depuis 1900 le début des années 80 le
gaz qui se transporte pas très bien
l'europe est en déclin de production
depuis 2005 et du coup le déclin
d'utilisation depuis cette époque
également et le pétrole est en plafond
d'extraction au niveau mondial depuis le
milieu des années 2000 l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie a fini par
reconnaître enfin 2018 que le pétrole
conventionnel dans le monde surtout ce
qui n'est pas le chez lloyd et tout ce
qui n'est pas les sables bitumineux
avait passé son pic en 2008
donc l'europe est en déclin
d'approvisionnement sur le pétrole sur
le charbon et sur le gaz
il ya eu une petite rémission ces
dernières années va pas durer et en plus
le déclin sur le pétrole va s'accélérer
parce que nous sommes servis pour
l'essentiel en europe par des zones en
déclin l'afrique est en déclin la russie
il est pas très loin de son déclin la
norvège est en déclin
voilà donc tous toutes les grandes zones
approvisionnements de l'europe sont en
déclin ou en passe de la dompter en
europe
nous n'avons pas le choix de toute façon
on va se décarbonés de gré ou de force
c'est pour ça pour en revenir au début
de cette discussion que je suis si
vénère comme dirait ma fille sur le fait
qu'on ait claqué des milliards dans un
truc qui sert à rien c'est à dire
l'arbitrage du quai à l'éolien alors
qu'on a le feu aux fesses et que ça
vaudrait sens du terme ça commence à
chauffer pour se dé carbonée en
préservant ce qu'on peut dans cette
affaire de stabilité sociale et de
prospérité économique
c'est sale c'est ça le but du jeu
c'est de préserver ce qu'on peu de
stabilité sociale et de prospérité
économique dans un monde qui va de toute
façon ce décarbonés et donc de toutes
façons voir son pib baisser petit petit
addendum sur le pib
vous allez me dire ces dernières années
il est reparti à la hausse
alors oui légèrement d'abord parce qu'on
a eu un petit surplus
d'approvisionnement énergétique à cause
du boom du shale oil et ensuite parce
qu'une partie du surplus de pib c'est du
faux pays des cantons compte le pays et
vous savez que l'on fait une correction
de l'inflation sur les biens courants
ça veut dire que si vous avez une paire
de chaussures qui l'année donner vos 100
euros et l'année d'après au 110 sorties
la même paire de chaussures quand on
compte le pib on l'a compte quand même
que pour 100 euros
on ne dit pas vous l'avez ou la boîte
vendu 110 mais en fait c'est vous avez
juste escroqué votre client entre
guillemets vous l'avez encore how they
thought he éclaboussant et donc je
compte toujours là ça vous ne faites pas
ça avec les actifs donc si un tableau
chez sotheby's valait 5 millions d'année
dernière et il vaut 50 millions l'année
prochaine
et bien vous allez vraiment faire entrer
50 millions plutôt que 5 dans le pib
alors cet effet là il joue sur le prix
de l'immobilier il joue sur la valeur
des actions il joue sur la valeur des
titres d'une manière générale donc vous
avez tout un tas de trucs pour
lesquelles la hausse de prix fait de la
hausse de pib alors que vous n'avez pas
plus de produits donc la correction de
l'inflation ne s'applique pas à
l'inflation des actifs qui soit dit en
passant est la grosse inflation qui a
été générée par la création monétaire
massive de ces dernières années c'est
pas l'inflation des biens courants
contrairement à ce que craignaient tous
les macroéconomistes bon teint qui
orthodoxe qui s'est opérée avec cet
afflux massif d'argent c'est l'inflation
des actifs que nous avons et en cette
inflation des actifs même
approvisionnements énergétiques constant
et à production constante matériel crée
du pib c'est un c'est un artefact mais
ça crée pas du pouvoir d'achat matériel
à voir avec ça c'est la raison pour
laquelle soit dit en passant le pouvoir
d'achat d'être des ménages lui il a
tendance à baisser depuis 2007 donc le
les gens s'en rendent compte donc le
donc la décarbonation encore une fois va
avec une contraction de l'économie
on sait pas faire autrement alors une
fois que j'ai dit ça la question c'est
comment est-ce que j'en fais un projet
prospère [ __ ] la boum
nous sommes tous très heureux c'est ça
la c'est ça la bonne question
et pour moi il faut que cette affaire
devienne un arbitrage qui soit un
arbitrage considéré comme acceptable
dit autrement le sens qu'on va donner la
part de confort matériel qu'on va
conserver parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on se dit tous les écolos on n'est
quand même pas prêt demain matin à aller
vivre à poil dans une caverne qu'elle
est en train dé rsa dépend haïti mais
même avec qui en plein hiver on va quand
même pas trouvé ça drôle et avec juste
le confort ce qu'on avait au moyen-âge
je pense que même parmi les plus écolos
des écolos il y en a beaucoup qui se
disent un peu d'électricité c'est quand
même sympa un peu de fois d'avoir trop
froid l'hiver c'est quand même sympa
donc même si c'est un poil avoir avoir
un moyen de communiquer avec les
semblables c'est quand même sympa manger
à sa faim c'est quand même sympa même si
on mange moins de viande ou pas du tout
donc il ya quand même quelques acquis de
la société moderne et puisse faire un
peu plaisir de temps en temps ceux des
pays d un peu de vivres 80 kilomètres de
chez soi et ne jamais aller voir
ailleurs c'est beaucoup d'écolos aussi
qu'ils sont pas nécessairement prêts à
faire ça approche du res les gens qui
ont la plus grande sensibilité
écologique sont aussi est trop
conservateur bat lyon trouve ça sympa
donc le donc la décroissance la vendre
ça ne marche pas il faut vendre des
projets dans lesquels l'arbitrage est
considérée comme encore acceptable alors
c'est quoi un arbitrage acceptable de
mon point de vue c'est un arbitrage dans
lequel on trouve suffisamment de sens et
suffisamment de dents vie de payer un
peu de sa personne pour stabiliser
l'avenir quelque part alors
qu'aujourd'hui l'avenir on y voit pas
clair et c'est un truc qui est
monstrueusement angoissant pour accepter
la part d'efforts que tout le monde va
devoir accepter même et y compris les
gens qui aujourd'hui il gagne le smic
alors ça suppose quand même un certain
nombre de choses que d'abord les gens
qui gagnent comme moi soient tendus plus
vite ce que les gens qui gagnent le smic
moi je suis d'accord dans un contexte
dans lequel le projet fait sens tant que
l'état fait le discours de politique
générale que j'ai eu il ya trois jours
je suis pas tellement d'accord pour
payer un centime de poids plus pour être
reversé au profit de conneries préfère
les garder pour moi
pour faire des choses qui sont utiles
pour la collectivité même même si je
préfère le faire donc je préfère la vie
de donner mon argent à des gens qui tu
trouves que donc il ya un consentement à
payer l'impôt qui est très très et a
donné pour la collectivité qui à mon
avis est très très profondément
indissociable du sens qu'on trouve au
projet collectif
donc je crois que c'est un cetain
quelque chose de très important de
savoir faire la pédagogie du défi à
relever et du projet qu'on a envie de
mettre en france alors le projet nous on
est à peu près capable de l'écrire
encore une fois je renvoie ou non aux
propositions du schiste plus tout ce
qu'on a pu pondre autour on voit à peu
près il faut évidemment créé
d'entousiasme donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on présente ce truc là comme la
grosse montagne sur laquelle on va
monter où la lune qu'on va conquérir
puis quand on est prêt à conquérir la
lune on est d'accord pour l'épicier dans
un scaphandre pendant une semaine ce qui
soit dit en passant est plutôt maigre et
après d'aller pisser dans les toilettes
et à manger de la boucle aux phillies et
dégueulasse pendant une semaine aussi
donc à partir du moment où il ya une
pédagogie du projet à une pédagogie de
l'effort je pense qu'on est capable de
faire quelque chose qui est de la
décroissance et on va la faire
essentiellement sous forme de sobriété
qui soit dit en passant est déjà en
train de s'organiser puisque le pouvoir
d'achat neil des ménages est déjà en
train un peu en train de diminuer par
exemple la colocation c'est la sobriété
vous aviez avant un appartement par
personne vous avez un appartement pour
trois personnes
c'est vous mutualiser la salle de bains
ont utilisé la cuisine vont mutualiser
les couloirs ou mutualisé pas les
chambres enfin ce qui est vraiment très
bien mais sinon vous avez à une forme de
sobriété covoiturage c'est la sobriété
à partir du moment où il ya une personne
sur deux est évidemment qu'ils renoncent
à s'acheter une voiture
je ne sais pas si c'est le cas mais
quand ça commencera à devenir le cas ça
devient rana la sobriété
vous avez donc un certain nombre de
choses comme ça qui sont déjà en train
de s'organiser
alors ça pose quelques problèmes
techniques cette histoire là est du
reste une question qui avait été posée à
rencontrer sa réponse à partir du moment
où cette sobriété et donc cette
récession est mise en place
le premier problème technique que ça
pose pardon excusez moi c'est que vos
revenus réels s est donc votre capacité
à rembourser vos empreintes baisse et
donc ça veut dire que tous les gens qui
ont une dette à rembourser avec leur
revenu réel pas en faisant de la
création monétaire je pense par exemple
à tous les gens qui ont un emprunt
immobilier sur le dos ils ont une
capacité à rembourser qui baisse et donc
il ya un risque de défaut qui augmente
c'est exactement pareil en ce qui
concerne les états puisque le pib c'est
la base fiscale c'est bien pour ça que
les plats sont si attachés à ce qu'il
augmente parce que l'essentiel des
impôts c'était un prélèvement sur une
fraction du pays des charges sociales
c'est un prélèvement sur une fraction du
pib l'impôt sur les sociétés c'est une
fraction sur le pib la tva est une
fraction du pib qui est prélevé et c'est
les impôts de stock donc les impôts
fonciers
la taxe sur la détention des télévisions
pour voir un truc ce genre de trucs sont
très très minoritaire dans la fiscalité
soit dit en passant si vous avez le pib
et qui baissent
évidemment que ça veut dire aussi que
quelque part la détention de la
propriété va devenir plus fortement
taxés
si on veut continuer en tout cas à
équilibrer les flux fiscaux
une autre solution c'est que l'état est
en moins de recettes et bien du coup ils
dépensent moins et alors il ya deux
manières de dépenses mois il doit
dépenser moins et peut virer des
fonctionnaires et rembourser la dette
c'est l'option qui a été prise jusqu'à
maintenant il peut ne pas virer les
fonctionnaires arrêtés d augmenter soit
dit en passant mais ça on va tous y
passer et considérer que la sécurité de
l'emploi ça pour ça mais par ailleurs ne
pas rembourser la dette et donc là ça
renvoie à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur l'assurance vie à ce moment
il ya une partie de votre assurance vie
qu'on pour rembourser alors la question
c'est est-ce que c'est très grave
ben je ne sais pas il ya une manière de
faire ça qui est une manière qui a été
expérimenté dans le passé soit dit en
passant qui s'appelle l'inflation à
partir du moment où les taux d'intérêt
qu'on vous sert sont inférieures au taux
d'inflation
eh bien vous avez une partie de votre
épargne qui font naturellement bon allez
vous n'avez pas une un défaut est pas
une rupture brutale simple
d'une année sur l'autre vous avez un peu
moins d'argent ça vous incite soit dit
en passant à le passer en consommation
et si par ailleurs il ya la
réglementation qui vous interdit de
consommer des trucs qui sont nuisibles
pour le climat ça va peut-être vous
incité par exemple alain cité dans la
rénovation de votre logement s'il en est
propriétaire
voilà vous avez une guerre maintien ce
n'est peut-être pas qu'on puisse que
toute façon cet argent devait le père
dont sylvia de francs suffisamment
basses comment je vais investir dans le
changement de chaudière l'isolation la
réfection du toit etc
parce que ça ça finira bien par avoir
une valeur patrimoniale dans un monde où
il ya moins d'énergie que dans un monde
où y'a moins d'énergie c'est plus
difficile de chauffer les bâtiments et
un bâtiment qui n'est pas chaud fable
vaut probablement moins cher au bout
d'un certain temps qu'un bâtiment qui
est chaud fable dont vous allez avoir
des arbitrages comme ça qu'ils vont qui
vont se faire donc le la grosse question
pour les finances publiques de d'un
projet de décarbonation à de grandes
ampleurs j'ai envie de dire est un est
un sujet de récession associés même si
pour ne rien vous cacher vous savez que
la stratégie nationale bas carbone dans
ce pays est une stratégie qui augmente
la croissance du pib
oui messieurs dames augmente la
croissance du pib est alors quand le
directeur général de l'énergie et du
climat a présenté cette conclusion à la
réunion du haut conseil où j'étais je
lui ai posé une question qui était quel
est le modèle utilisé pour arriver à ça
et alors en fait le modèle utilisé
il postule que la productivité du
travail est indépendante de la quantité
d'énergie dont on dispose
lorsqu'il fait la productivité du
travail c'est la quantité de machines
quand vous adjoint puisque le travail
n'est pas plus productif parce que vous
avez plus de bras et jambes il est plus
productif parce que vous avez accès à
plus de machines si vous avez accès à
plus de machine vous avez accès à plus
d'énergie donc si vous avez une
stratégie nationale bas carbone qui vous
divise les émissions par huit ou neuf en
l'espace de trente ans je parie mes
économies contre qui veulent un qui
écoute en ce moment que ça c'est
totalement incompatible avec le fait qu
on augmente la quantité d'énergie
disponible pour les machines qui
produisent donc on augmente le pib c'est
l'exact inverse qu on obtiendra bien
calmes et vida
en fait j'ai été regardé le modèle qui
était utilisée il a un pib qui est
fourni en entrée vous avez un pib qui ai
postulé croissant en entrée et comme
c'est un modèle dans lequel les
investisse quand vous faites des
investissements ça augmente le pib pour
décarbonés faut faire des
investissements donc le pib augmente par
hypothèse qui ont fait des
investissements donc ils augmentent
encore plus à peu près aussi aussi bête
que ça
enfin ces bêtes à double titre c'est à
dire le raisonnement est simple et la
conclusion est stupide donc le donc le
la décarbonation je le redis pose un
problème sur les recettes publiques et
donc vous avez vu de manière d'arbitrer
la troisième manière d'arbitrer et sait
faire fonctionner la planche à billets
mais ça en france c'est une option nous
n'avons plus puisque la planche à
billets et cassis à l'europe du coup ça
pose une question à laquelle je n'ai pas
la réponse donc personne ne me fasse
dire ce que je ne vais pas dire qui est
que ceux qui disent qu'il faut sortir de
l'euro pour retrouver la souveraineté
monétaire qui permet justement de faire
fonctionner la planche à billets qui
permet justement de faire pleins
d'inflation pour apurer la dette tout en
déca revenant ou un point c'est un
argument qui mérite examen
je pense que ça ne peut pas balayer d'un
revers de la main revers de la main je
suis pas complètement persuadé que tous
les gens qui aujourd'hui veulent sortir
de l'euro le faire pour cette raison là
par contre c'est clairement un point
la deuxième chose qu'il faut faire si on
a un projet de décarbonation donc de
sobriété c'est qu'il faut faire tout ce
qu'on peut pour que les gens qui vont
voir leurs revenus baisser et en face
leurs charges qui baissent parce qu'à
partir du moment où vous divisez votre
revenu par deux qui dans le même temps
vous diviser vos charges par de bons
sens fou voilà y'a juste pas de sujet
vous avez par exemple des gens qui sont
retraités et qui ont leurs revenus qui
est visé par deux qui émigrent au
portugal alors évidemment c'est très mal
parce qu'avec l'argent des contribuables
français
c'est à dire les charges sur les
salaires que verse mon entreprise
ils font tourner l'économie portugaise
moi je préférerais qu'il fasse tourner
l'économie française évidemment j'ai
beaucoup de portugais cela étant ce
n'est pas le sujet les jonctions très
sympa et qui font de l'excellent morue
mais à part ça le
la question de la diminution du revenu
des pas un drame si dans le même temps
vous dit me de charges qui est très
exactement ce que font les gens qui vont
au portugal avec la retraite ils ont
l'air d'être très content avec des
charges diminué en phase de revue
diminué donc comment est-ce qu'on
organise la diminution des charges
et bien c'est toute la question donc il
faut par exemple baisser les loyers
alors baisser les loyers vous avez qu'à
10 rebonds en encadrer les loyers
oui sauf que la physique fait que la
rareté se paye toujours à un moment ou
un autre
donc une autre solution c'est de sortir
les gens des grandes villes donc
aujourd'hui vous avez un urbanisme une
gestion de l'espace en france qui est on
va concentrer tous les gens dans les
grandes métropoles c'est comme ça qu'on
en a une plus grosse que le voisin des
propos d'évident et qu' on est des gens
qui comptent plus sur la scène
internationale oui sauf que ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est absolument pas
résilient dans un monde qui doivent
décarbonée parce que dans un monde qui
doit se déclare bonne et on est pas
capable d'assurer aux gens de vie de
quoi vivre correctement avec peu
d'argent dans une grande ville par
ailleurs une grande ville
elle a un hinterland extrêmement étendue
c'est à dire qu'elle a besoin de flux en
provenance de très très loin pour lui
permettre de vivre parce que si vous en
passer dix millions de personnes c'est
de la géométrie
si vous en passer dix millions de
personnes au même endroit le disque qui
est nécessaire pour nourrir ces gens-là
surfaces agricoles autour de la ville
évidemment beaucoup plus importante que
si vous avez an passé cinquante mille
personnes
donc si vous avez une distance que vous
pouvez parcourir par jour avec et
transport de nourriture qui est donnée
une fois pour toutes ça vous donne la
taille maximale de la ville que vous
êtes capable de nourrir avec les
transports en question et moins vous
aurez d'énergie moins vous aurez de
transport donc moins vous serez capable
de nourrir une ville importante dans un
monde rend contraintes fortes sur
l'énergie donc c'est une autre raison
pour laquelle il faut faire dégonfler
les grandes villes et il faut remettre
les gens plus près des ressources dont
on aura besoin dans un monde qu'ils des
carbones et ses ressources c'est quoi
c'est la biomasse c'est la terre c'est
les quelques ressources minières est qui
qui ont besoin d'être prête assez
exploité par dont c'est la mer c'est le
vent c'est le soleil c'est les mines
d'uranium
évidemment et tout ce qui va derrière
donc le
donc la manière de gérer l'occupation de
l'espace dans un monde qui se déclarent
bonne est une manière qui n'a
strictement rien à voir avec celle
utilisée aujourd'hui mais qui
al'avantage si on s'y prend bien de
faire quand même raisonnablement baisser
une partie des charges importantes des
ménages aujourd'hui qui est le loyer la
deuxième chose que vous faites baisser
dans ce contexte là c'est j'ai envie de
dire les des consommation compulsive
liées au stress dans les villes par
exemple vous avez plein de consommateurs
compulsifs parce qu'il faut se
déstresser donc on achète on est sûr
équipée en écrans machin etc on s'abonne
à plein de trucs on va dans les clubs de
sport tout ça quand vous êtes dans un
environnement qui est plus lâche vous
est fourni gratuitement par la nature
quand vous êtes pour ceux d'entre eux
qui ont la chance d'y aller en vacances
au bord de la plage et bien ou bien de
vous la vouliez de vous abonner à des
tweaks le soir vous allez vous balader
sur la plage et c'est tout aussi sympa
pour ceux d'entre vous qui l'ont fait et
puis vous avez la possibilité vous est
moins tenté tout ce qu'il ya moins de
commerce
et puis l'achat compulsif peut être
remplacé par le fait d'aller gratter les
mauvaises herbes
autour de ces rosiers donc vous avez
tout un tas de trucs qui sont non
marchand dans ce genre de l'espace alors
vous allez me dire s'il ya moins de
trucs marchand l'économie produit - ah
ben oui mais sauf que comme je dis
qu'elle va produire moins justement la
boucle est bouclée
donc vous avez un sujet sur
l'aménagement de l'espace qui
aujourd'hui alors il commence à être
pris à petit à petit dos ce sujet j'ai
vu passer il ya pas longtemps un
colloque qui aura lieu au sénat à la
rentrée je sais pas ce qu'on m'a demandé
d'aller causé malheureusement je
pourrais pas en france que je précieux
atouts pour y aller mais apparemment
avec une poignée d'urbanistes
tendance astérix là qui ont commencé à
réfléchir à cette question alors j'en
reviens à la question de la décroissance
est ce que ça implique donc ça implique
aussi cette décroissance cette sobriété
cette décarbonation qu'on va devoir
diminuer la taille maximale physique
admissibles des organisations donc c'est
quelque chose
une bonne partie des multinationales
sont averse à cette idée pour une raison
assez simple c'est que c'est très
compliqué de maintenir le
multinationales qui a besoin de flux
très intense à très large échelle
beaucoup d'énergie pour maintenir sa
cohésion interne
si vous pouvez pas faire des séminaires
tous les six mois en ramenant tous les
cas dans l'avion c'est compliqué de
maintenir la cohésion interne alors à
l'époque on avait des croyances il y
avait une multinationale à forte on va
dire il y avait une multinationale
mondiale c'est l'église
on est arrivé avec des chevaux mais
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué de maintenir
ce genre de grandes organisations à
large échelle avec juste des avec juste
des croyances et donc vous avez un
[Musique]
difficultés dans un monde qui se
contracte à maintenir ses grandes
organisations
il y aura une autre difficulté
évidemment c'est que comme c'est
décroissance ne vont pas s'opérer à la
même vitesse
vous allez avoir des jaloux c'est à dire
que si nous on voit nos revenus divisés
par 2 pendant que chez le voisin ils ont
enlevé que 20%
évidemment on va avoir des voilà donc
c'est évident que c'est un truc qui va
être très compliqué à gérer mais je le
redis la décarbonation est de fait et
elle a commencé une contraction de
l'économie
alors il ya une chose qui pourrait être
faite également et j'en veux beaucoup
aux économistes qui ne le font pas
qu'ils sont payés avec l'argent de mes
impôts
vous savez qu'une bonne partie de la
recherche en économie dans ce pays
relève de la fonction publique et la
fonction publique est payé avec l'argent
de mes impôts et des vôtres et de ceux
qui nous écoutent et de ceux qui nous
écoutent pas donc à partir du moment où
c'est payé avec l'argent de mes impôts
j'aimerais bien avoir voix au chapitre
sur ce que ces gens là doivent faire
pour partie et il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui comme on ne peut pas à
tout le moins exclure et
vraisemblablement on va la voir une
contraction du pib
plutôt que tous ils cherchent ce qu'on
fait dans vraiment dans croissance ce
qui correspond à un cahier des charges
qui n'est pas nécessairement celui qu'on
va avoir
j'aimerais bien qu'il ya une fraction
croissante qui se penche sur la question
de qu'est ce qu'on fait si la croissance
n'est pas là et que le système se
contracte et je considère que ça serait
pas de l'argent jeté par la fenêtre que
au moins 5 ou 10% des budgets et
laboratoires de recherche en économie
soit consacrée à employer des gens qui
lisent
supposons que donc je leur demande pas
d'être d'accord avec l'hypothèse de
départ ni ne la trouvait désirable mais
supposons que le système entre en
contraction structurelles quelle est la
moins mauvaise manière de commencer à
gérer ce bastringue bon et aujourd'hui
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'une partie de
l'argent de mes impôts soit orientée sur
cette recherche
là ils n'ont pas sur comment est ce
qu'on fait revenir la croissance alors
que manifestement elle n'en revient pas
si facilement que ça tout simplement
parce que ça dépend d'un truc sur
laquelle on n'a pas nécessairement de la
prise c'est à dire de l'énergie voilà
alors autre petit couplet sur la
décroissance
qu'est-ce qu'on va demander d'autre que
devient finance donc ça c'est ce que
devient la recherche
eh bien il faut qu'elles cherchent sur
comment on gère aussi c'est moins de
croissance a alors maintenant deux
questions ville petit village ça c'est
fait solution à l'équation caillaouère
ça je peux répondre
l'équation de callas pour ceux d'entre
vous qui ne connaissent pas c'est cette
fameuse règle de 3 qui relie les
émissions de co2 à la population
mondiale le pib par personne
l'énergie par unité de pib et le co2 par
unité d'énergie
voilà pour je renvoie la page de mon
site s'appelle question à l'équation
qu'il ya pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
été voir il ya une solution à l'équation
de kaya qui passe par une population qui
augmente encore un peu un pib mondial
qui se stabilise mais qui se stabilise
ça veut dire que si on est dans un
régime communiste c'est à dire que
l'indien et moi j'ai droit la même
journée en droit la même chose les
français doivent utiliser leur part 3
voilà pour le savoir
et à ce moment en faisant 1 à 2 %
d'efficacité énergétique par an et 1 à
2% de décarbonation de l'énergie par an
ça passe à peu près c'est plus aux
documents du reste pour diviser les
émissions de co2 par trois en trente ans
donc il ya donc voyez si le pib mondial
se maintient alors en fait dans une
vision très pragmatique le pib de
l'indien miens ce égaliseront pas
totalement le pays de l'ornière il sera
un peu inférieure
ça veut dire que en gros avec une
division du pib par deux en france une
en or
alors est-ce que c'est grave de diviser
le pib par deux surtout si les revenus
sont divisés par 4 pendant que celui du
smicard ne perd que très peu aux 30% pas
complètement sûr je encore une fois si
en face on a un défi qui nous
enthousiasme je suis pas complètement
désespéré un parallèle que j'ai souvent
fait dans le passé que je fais moins
souvent maintenant mais que je préfère
c'est que on a quand même trouvé en 1914
et 1939 des gens qui étaient très
heureux à l'idée d'aller se faire tuer
probablement que d'avoir juste son
revenu divisé par deux parce qu'on
participe à une stabilisation du monde
et à quelque chose qui assurent la paix
à nos enfants et du reste à une bonne
partie des gens qui m'écoutent parce
qu'ils sont plus jeunes que moi
peut-être pas complètement stupide de se
dire que le trou que jouable
par contre ce qui est absolument évident
à mon esprit c'est que la démarche les
chefs doit être exemplaire dans cette
histoire dit autrement exhorté la
population à l'effort quand on a pas soi
même latitude gaullienne qui consiste à
payer ses notes de frais à l'elysée de
sa propre poche alors je parle pas juste
pour qu'il rende mâcon jeu je dise plus
largement l'élite
c'est quelque chose qui n'a aucune
chance de passer donc les les gens qui
ont envie d'entraîner le pays au poste
de commandement dans cette affaire de
décarbonation se devront d'être
exemplaire à la fois dans les
comportements et dans les tic
ils se devront d'être est de fournir une
part de l'effort qu'ils soient plus
importantes que celles qui demandent aux
autres voilà si ils font pas ça n'a
aucune chance de marcher alors on
brocarde damgan dans les ministres qui
se met à rouler à vélo etc
moi je dis non ça fait partie du deal en
suède par exemple le ministre prend le
vélo et prendre et prend le métro
et soit dit en passant quand il vient
conclure un colloque qui reste le
colloque dans tout le contraire de nos
ministres français et bien je ne vois
pas en quoi c'est ridicule au contraire
pour moi c'est cohérent avec ce qu'on
demande aux autres de faire et soit dit
en passant si une partie des gens qui
nous gouvernent tourner plus souvent le
métro que ils ne le font je pense que ça
leur permettrait un peu moins souvent
les voitures avec chauffeur je pense que
ça donnera une idée des réalités de ce
monde
l'élu et le alors est-ce que j'en étais
du coup du père du fils à huy donc la
solution à l'équation carrière donc
voilà la solution à l'équation de
qu'ailleurs en france
elle passe par pib divisé par deux à
fond les ballons sur la décarbonation de
l'énergie décarbonée l'énergie en france
c'est s'attaquer au pétrole et au gaz
c'est pas s'attaquer au nucléaire et
augmenter l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie
on a peu de marges dans l'industrie ce
que ça fait très longtemps et en
particulier dans l'industrie lourde
parce que c'est des semaines qu'ils se
des domaines qui sont très énergivores
il ya quelques sweets technologiques qui
sont encore à notre portée par exemple
utiliser l'hydrogène pour réguler mina
de faire ou pas encore là mais on peut
espérer quelque chose qui sera mieux que
le moyen-âge et on peut espérer que ça
dure suffisamment longtemps si on décide
de parra contre la population
alors après on a d'autres problèmes de
cycle qui ont été transgressés le cycle
de la zot lé fonds tendant de la
biodiversité etc on a encore du pain sur
la planche mais la surpêche truc mais
sur la partie carbone j'ai envie de dire
on peut ne pas être complètement
désespéré à partir du moment où on
considère que l'effort collectif qui
parle du rugby vous de transpirer est-ce
qu'on va devoir deviendra redevenir en
partie à la culture j'ai répondu à la
question la réponse est oui bien
alors sur l'agriculture juste en passant
le la vision que je défends consiste à
dire qu'il faut partiellement des
spécialisés les régions encadrer les
prix augmenter les exigences de qualité
en contrepartie de quoi on augmente très
fortement les prix en sortie
d'exploitation mais il faut les
augmenter de la lyre garantit donc c'est
bien pour ça que je dis qu'on les
encadre et c'est très cohérent avec la
façon dont les agriculteurs procèdent
déjà quand ils ont des labels aoc aop et
ces chartes typiquement les prix
auxquels on achète le lait pour faire du
comté ou du beaufort sont des prix
garantis des prix élevés en contrepartie
qu les agriculteurs ont un cahier des
charges ça veut dire en pratique diviser
le cheptel bovin par deux faut quand
même garder des animaux parce que ça
fait des amendements pour les champs
donc si on veut plus d'engrais de
synthèse on est bien obligé de garder
les animaux qui chez un peu partout
c'est voilà c'est la contrepartie il
faut augmenter l'agroforesterie remettre
des aides il y la taille des parcelles
revenir à de la polyculture élevage
voilà sortir du système des prix
mondiaux qui sont une ânerie je ne vois
pas de raison valable à ce que le prix
mondial des céréales qui concerne 10%
des céréales qui sont produites dans le
monde si vous avez 10 % des céréales
produites dans le monde qui passe une
frontière
je vois pas pourquoi ça servirait de des
changes au prix de f1 de des talons
pardon aux prix domestiques à droite et
à gauche une espèce de rationalité dans
mon travail avoir des prix domestiques
différent des prix mondiaux
bref comme ça si on encadre soit dit en
passant on peut sécuriser les volumes ça
peut être fait de manière réglementaire
donc vous avez le sur l'agriculture en
gros dans les grandes lignes
et il faut augmenter la valeur ajoutée à
la faire donc ça veut dire que la ferme
doit faire moins de produits bruts et
plus de produits transformés alors
l'exemple typique c'est dans l'élevage
vous faites moins de lait vont être plus
de yaourts plus de fromage c'est
l'exemple typique
vous avez de la voilà en fait je moins
de moins de volailles vendues vivante ou
moins de volailles vendues entière et
vous faites plus de pathé jeu pourquoi
c'est terrible vous avez là il s'est
déjà produit transformé quelque part
donc vous avez un vous avez là il faut
faire il faut faire monter les
exploitations valeur ajoutée il devrait
c'est comme ça que se sortent les gens
qui s'installent en bio
maraîchage il monte en valeur ajoutée où
il capte la russe la rente de
distribution par exemple à travers les
amap où ils font des produits
transformés ils font des ratatouilles
des sauces et c'est qu'ils vont rendre
la coopérative du point donc le donc le
modèle alors ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
arrêter d'avoir des grandes cultures en
totalité ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
mais il faut fortement remettre le
balancier dans le sens inverse de ce qu
on a fait quand on à revendre et c'est
des exploitations en monoculture à 500
hectares
alors évidemment les céréaliers dans la
beauce dont un togolais tout un tas
d'autres gens vont en profiter voilà ses
shooteurs en plein destruction créatrice
alors il ya un tout un volet dans cette
affaire-là et donc je veux faire le lien
avec quand même un petit coupé nucléaire
sur la résilience des infrastructures
est en fait le nucléaire non mais qu'un
un exemple paris parmi d'autres donc en
gros on comment est ce qu'on est capable
de continuer à entretenir des
infrastructures dans un contexte de
contraction
alors il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
l'essentiel du pib va quand même dans
des dépenses de consommation
aujourd'hui la formation brute de
capital fixe si ma mémoire est bonne en
france est de l'ordre de 20% du pib donc
je peux très bien dans un pib qui est
divisé par deux passer à 40% du pib qui
va dans cette formation brute de capital
fixe et continuer à maintenir les
infrastructures
donc ça ne pose pas de problème de
principe à partir du moment si le pib /
10 c'est à dire que là c'est vraiment
madmax pour de vrai là effectivement en
v6 est vraiment mad max pour de vrai je
rassure tout le monde l'essentiel
d'entre vous seront mort bien avant que
l accident nucléaire qui hurle on sera
mort des buts de guerre civile
sabine et de plaisanteries de cela si on
voilà donc si on en arrive au point où
on n'est même plus capable d'entretenir
les infrastructures vitales du pays
parce que le pays dépasse en dessous des
dépenses de renouvellement et
l'entretien de ces infrastructures plus
ce qu'il faut mettre dans la bouffe je
vous assure que l'on se rappelle normal
qu'on n'a pas que ça comme problème
alors j'ai maintenant puisqu'il ya quand
même toute une tripotée de questions sur
le nucléaire alors avec son certaines
d'entre elles sont un peu technique donc
j'espère que l'audience m'excuseras et
certaines d'entre elles je vais aller
assez vite
est ce que le nucléaire résiste à une
contraction du pib alors on a au moins
un point d'échantillonnage ça ne s'est
pas une règle absolue mais on en a un
qui s'appelle ukraine l'ukraine a doublé
sa production nucléaire depuis 1986 donc
depuis l'accident de tchernobyl et
s'étaler pourtant de pair avec un pays
qui s'est effondré économiquement
puisque son pib a été divisé par deux et
comme vous avez pu le constater c'est il
n'y a pas eu d'accident
donc ils ont eu un accident à l'époque
où le pib a été plus élevé en ce sens
toutes les conneries qu'il peut le faire
mais par contre il n'y a pas eu
d'accident lié à la division du pib par
deux il ya un deuxième
voilà donc je ne suis pas complètement
persuadés que ce que ce soit quelque
chose qui y va au niveau
d'investissement que sa demande
nous nous devons nous mettre dans la
catastrophe parlons chiffres la
reconstruction à neuf du parc nucléaire
français ça serait allé avec tout ce que
demande la snc un tir bretelles inutile
300 milliards d'euros sur la durée 60
ans donc ça veut dire que ces 5
milliards d'euros par an en annuités oui
donc le pib français aujourd'hui ses
2200 milliards d'euros donc il faudrait
qu'il soit divisé par 100 pour que on
commence à avoir un vrai problème pour
payer ça soit dit en passant si les / ça
on n'a pas besoin d'autres centrales
nucléaires aujourd'hui le 10e gagnent
nucléaire on n'aura pas qu'on aura
personne à qui vendre l'électricité donc
le l'idée qu'on soit atteint fortement
moi ça me voilà ça me perturbe pas trop
2e cat deuxième question sur le
nucléaire le refroidissement alors le
refroidissement parlons chiffres le vous
avez deux catégories de centrales
nucléaires en france dans les centrales
nucléaires bord de mer qui en général ne
sont pas montrés à la télévision que la
télévision est bien montré les tours de
refroidissement qui ne sont pas
l'apanage du nucléaire mais qui sont
l'apanage des centrales thermiques en
bord de rivière donc une centrale à
charbon en allemagne au bord de rivières
et la très belle aéroréfrigérants aussi
avec un très beau panache de vapeur
au-dessus
c'est les centrales qui sont en bord de
mer dont par exemple gravelines ou penly
où flamanville sont des centrales qui
sont refroidis par la mer donc la source
froide c'est qu'on va se servir de la
mer qui a une énorme capacité dilutive
en termes thermique comme sur ce froid
blé dont vous n'avez pas d'aero
réfrigérant donc si la télévision vous
montrer ils ont craint le nucléaire à
chaque fois qu'il soit celle de
flamanville par exemple ou celle de
penly
eh bien vous diriez pas que ça fumait
que c'est chaud dans les centrales en
bord de rivière la plus grosse qu'on ait
ces quatre noms qui a qui demande un
débit en eau pour se refroidir quand
elle fonctionne à pleine puissance de 2
mètres cubes par seconde
dit autrement look il faut prélever dans
la rivière et qu'on ne remettra pas dans
la rivière parce qu'on l'a évaporés dans
l' hérault et free gérant pour refroidir
le réacteur
parce que l'évaporation consomment
beaucoup de chaleur c'est la chaleur
latente d'élaboration eh bien ces deux
mètres cubes à la seconde la meuse la
moselle je me souviens jamais qui
refroidit 4 non à un débit d'étiage
aujourd'hui qui descend à 12 mètres
cubes seconde
vous voyez c'est pas complètement
négligeable 2 sur 12 mais ça reste
quelque chose qui est physiquement
possible
et puis quand vous êtes en plein hiver
et que le truc tourne à plein régime là
par contre le débit est de 150 ou 200
mètres cubes à la seconde donc là vous
avez strictement aucun problème d'accès
à refroidissement
alors il se trouve par ailleurs que
l'été c'est l'époque préférentiels ou
comme on consomme beaucoup moins
d'électricité on arrête les centrales
pour la maintenance ou bien on les fait
fonctionner un volume plus réduit
parce que on n'a pas besoin de toute
l'électricité du coup on a besoin de
moins d'eau de refroidissement
si un jour la voisine se retrouvent à
sec qu'est ce qu'on fait eh ben on
arrête
quatre noms voilà c'est à peu près aussi
bête que ça alors il faut quand même
avoir un tout petit peu d'eau une fois
que le réacteur est arrêté et a cessé de
produire mais là pour le coup c'est plus
un mètre cubes à la seconde qu'il vous
faut c'est un litre à la seconde
on est dans ces ordres de grandeur là
donc on est très très en-deça là pour le
coup il n'y a pas de problème de sûreté
majeur
parce que ces blocs on aura donc le
suffit d'amener quelques camions
citernes au pire et on sait et on sait
reproduire le réacteur alors alors bon
ça empêchera les gens de ce qui m'a qui
n'est pas très grave si ca peut être les
gens ça n'empêchera pas les gens au
niveau actuel de climatisation mais est
ce qu'on risque au pire c'est ça donc le
donc le problème aujourd'hui n'est pas
un problème quand les centrales
fonctionnent à pleine puissance pourrait
en être un à l'avenir mais à ce moment
il en sera un toutes les centrales
thermiques en bord de rivière c'est à
dire que les centrales thermiques au
charbon en allemagne ont exactement le
même problème donc à ce moment la
question est donc devront être arrêtées
exactement de la même manière alors
elles n'auront pas besoin du litres par
seconde pour le refroidissement
résiduelles mais encore une fois solides
par seconde est pas un sujet qui est un
sujet majeur donc le la cette question
du de l'eau de refroidissement est un
problème éventuel de disponibilité ça
n'est pas un problème de sûreté enfin en
tout cas pas à ce stade
qu'est ce que je pense du ter que ça
sert à rien je vais pas m'étaler
là-dessus parce que j'en ai déjà parlé
un certain nombre de fois mon analyse
sur l'état de vétusté du parc nucléaire
français
alors l'état de vétusté du parc
nucléaire français est un débat
intéressant parce qu'en fait la vétusté
dans une centrale ça n'a pas tellement
de sens le seul élément qui peut avoir
de la vétusté dans une centrale si la
cuve du réacteur
quand vous faites une centrale là le
seul élément que vous ne pourrez plus
changé une fois que la centrale est
rentré en fonctionnement
c'est la cuve du réacteur ait une partie
de la tuyauterie qui va avec tout le
reste sera changé au moins une fois dans
le cadre de la vie normale de la
centrale est par exemple fessenheim qui
a une donnée centrale qui a été
construite en premier en france est une
des centrales où on a changé le plus de
choses depuis le démarrage de la
centrale ce qui fait que paradoxalement
c'est probablement une des centrales les
plus sûrs du parc france l'arrêt de
fessenheim est une décision politique
le fait que la centrale soit la plus
vieille de deux parcs n'est pas un
élément devait de vulnérabilité en tant
que tel il ya des tas de bâtiments qui
sont beaucoup moins d'eau que les
pyramides et qui sont en construction
effondré
l'écart à vide donc c'est pas encore une
fois l'âge n'est pas un critère qui est
suffisant pour déterminer si quelque
chose est vulnérable
le don ce qui détermine l'organisme qui
détermine si une centrale et minérales
ou pas vulnérable en france ça existe
s'appelle l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
elle est particulièrement féroce on a
probablement l'autorité la plus féroce
au monde
encouragés en ce moment par un pouvoir
politique
donc c'est des gens qui sont vraiment
extrêmement catillon et l'autorité de
sûreté
tous les 10 ans passe dans une centrale
indépendamment de ce que le constructeur
vous a vendu donc en constructeur vous
dis je vous l'avant pour 40 ans en fait
il vous vend une fausse promesse
et en fait il ne vous vend pas cette
promesse soit dit en passant le
constructeur il vous vend une centrale
où les composants sont dimensionnés
éventuellement pour résister au moins 40
ou bien il nous vend une centrale où
vous allez faire vous allez avoir la la
licence ou plus pour 40 ans aux états
unis par exemple la loi antitrust
interdit de donner des licences pour
plus de 40 ans donc en fait c'est pas
une durée de vie 40 ans c'est une durée
de fonctionnement autorisé avant que on
vous remet est entre guillemets dans le
marché pour savoir si on vous renouvelle
votre licence le lin freixe ans pour le
fonctionnement d'une centrale c'est ce
qu'on appelle la visite décennale c'est
à dire que tous les dix ans l'autorité
de sûreté passe chez vous vous regarde
sous toutes les coutures ou déshabille
vous inspectent les tréfonds des
entrailles et vous dit soit ça va bien
comme ça et vous continuez soit ça va
bien comme ça à condition que vous vous
rajoutiez tels étaient les trucs que je
demande en plus c'est à cette condition
seulement vont continuer ou bien ça va
pas du tout je ferme
vous avez eu en france des centrales
nucléaires que l'ancêtre de l'autorité
de sûreté
à l'époque il n'y avait pas d' autorité
de sûreté indépendante des centrales qui
ont été fermées par idf c'est toute la
filière graphite gaz qui soit dit en
passant et en démantèlement en ce moment
donc quand vous entendez dans la presse
qu'on ne sait pas démanteler un réacteur
on peut trouver ça difficile
on peut avoir des difficultés à le faire
mais quand vous lisez au pardon on l'a
jamais démantelé mais qu'on a jamais les
manches et ses faux pas des réacteurs en
cours de démantèlement en france mans
avec un problème géographique soit dit
en passant qui est pas très simple à
résoudre mais le démantèlement il ya des
taux d'installation qui sont en cours de
démantèlement en france un type de
réacteur de recherche l'ancêtre de
superphénix il appelle félix qui est un
réacteur rapide c'est à dire au fond du
exactement comme super phénix et qui a
très bien marché soit dit en passant est
en cours de démantèlement voilà donc
vous avez tout un tas d'installation qui
sont en cours de démantèlement dans ce
pays donc le donc l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire passe chez vous et vous dit il
va falloir faire ça si vous voulez que
ça continue à fonctionner et les
réacteurs qui a gravi gaz et bien
l'ancêtre de la dir de l'autorité de
sûreté a dit il faut rajouter ceci cela
est déjà fait ses comptes a dit c'est
pas rentable je plie correct et c'est
exactement ça le dialogue entre
l'autorité de sûreté et des f
c'est à dire que l'autorité de sûreté
pas dit ça va bien si vous rajoutez ceci
cela est d elle fait ses comptes
l'exploitant fait ses comptes en
l'occurrence en france et qu'edf et il
dit ça vaut le coup ça vaut pas le coup
si ça vous plaît couillard est puis si
ça vaut le coup il fait les
investissements et à ce moment
l'autorité de sûreté vérifie qu des
investissements ont été bien fait et dit
je signe pour dix ans supplémentaires
donc c'est pas moi c'est pas vous et
c'est pas le président de la république
qui décide si une centrale et entre
guillemets vétustes ou pas vétuste et à
dire présente un risque ou pas un risque
c'est l'autorité de sûreté c'est son
rôle il est passé par dessus la tête de
l'autorité de sûreté en misant cette
centrale n'est pas sûr où cette centrale
est trop vieille pour fonctionner ce
café hollande quand il a dit on va
fermer fessenheim
c'est une imposture vous pouvez dire je
veux faire cette centrale pour des
raisons politiques parce que c'est un
totem et que je me contrefous de savoir
si c'est raisonnable rationnelle ou et
cetera mais c'est un totem déjà faire
notre reçu votre droit le plus strict
rien ni personne n'a écrit que la
décision politique interdit de faire des
conneries
par contre dire je la ferme parce que je
considère sur la base d'un élément
technique il n'est pas invoqué par l'asn
en l'occurrence en âge ça c'est une
imposture donc je répète le seul sujet
qui demande vraiment qu'on le regarde de
près c'est la cuve tout le respect de
changer donc on change aux états unis la
quasi-totalité des centrales qui ont été
autorisés pour 40 ans le sont
aujourd'hui pour 60
c'est à dire que les exploitants ont
demandé un renouvellement de leur
licence et on leur a accordé vingt ans
supplémentaires la quasi-totalité des
réacteurs en fonctionnement aux états
unis vont fonctionner 20 ans de plus
alors il ya une différence entre la
philosophie française et la 10ième fille
allemande
ah oui et la philosophie américaine
c'est que la philosophie américaine
c'est que à tout instant le réacteur
doit être conforme à ses spécifications
de départ vous n'avez pas besoin de
faire des investissements en cours de
route pour augmenter la sûreté
alors qu'en france à tout instant il
doit être conforme à l'état de l'art
donc l'asn peut exiger des
investissements pour augmenter la sûreté
ce qui de mon point de vue est une bonne
chose
avec un bémol c'est que l'asn devrait
avoir l'obligation ce qu'elle n'a pas
aujourd'hui de faire une analyse coûts
bénéfices des mesures qu'elle demande
dit autrement si les mesures qu'elle
demande au motif que ça prévient un
risque conduisent par exemple à plonger
trop souvent la france dans le noir
parce qu'on arrête plein de centrales à
ce moment vous avez un autre risque les
hôpitaux fonctionnent plus les
transports fonctionnent plus et sert à
ça vous fait plein de morts partout
beaucoup plus qu'avec un accident
nucléaire
et bien aujourd'hui l'asn n'a pas le
mandat de mettre ces risques en balance
et personnellement je pense qu'elle
devrait avoir le mandat de m siège quand
valence avant de demander quelque chose
à l'exploitant mais voilà c'est ça le
c'est ça mon petit ajout est ce qu'on
peut avoir des petits réacteurs
nucléaires la réponse est bien sûr oui
puisque les réacteurs nucléaire
historique
ils ont propulsé des bâtiments de guerre
avant de servir à faire de l'électricité
donc on sait faire des réacteurs qui
sont beaucoup plus petits que les
réacteurs ont fait aujourd'hui pour la
génération électrique par contre vous
avez un effet d'échelle dans les
réacteurs pour la génération électrique
qui fait qu'on a intérêt et comme
invitant à faire des gros réacteurs pour
la génération électrique mais on sait
faire des petits réacteurs par exemple
les réacteurs qui alimente les sous
marins nucléaires d'attaqué
de mémoire c'est des réacteurs qui font
quelques dizaines de mégawatts de
puissance électrique
c'est beaucoup plus petit qu'un de ppr
qui fait 1600 mégawatts de puissance
électrique
il ya une voie de recherche actuellement
qui consiste à faire ce qu'on appelle
des petits réacteur modulaire alors pour
que ça soit vraiment intéressant cette
histoire il faut pas que vous ayez des
effets 2d échelle
il faut pas que vous ayez des
infrastructures annexes qui valent le
même coup quelle que soit la puissance
du réacteur que ce soit 1600 mégawatts
où que ce soit 50 mégawatts parce que là
du coup si vous avez ça vous augmenter
fortement
le prix de l'électricité encore qu'on
pourrait considérer que ces points suit
ce qui soit dit en passant n'est pas
très très lourd que mon point de vue
est-ce qu'il faut relancer le
surgénérateur et la fusion la fusion
j'ai répondu ça n'a aucun intérêt d'ici
à ce que je meure est ici à ce que tous
les gens qui me regardent moeurs par
contre la surgénération oui il faut
d'urgence lancé un programme fasttrack
de mon point de vue sur le nucléaire
quatrième génération alors est-ce que ça
va nous sauver et ramener la croissance
pour boucler avec ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la réponse est non rien ne
ramènera la croissance
par contre ça va amortir la décroissance
est donc ça va faire une petite partie
de la différence entre le moyen-age
complet est quelque chose qui est un
état intermédiaire dont avec beaucoup
d'espoir et beaucoup de blagues idiotes
on arrivera dans lequel on arrivera à
trouver notre bonheur quand même donc le
et donc mais le nucléaire durable est un
nucléaire dans lequel on lance la
quatrième génération parce qu'on n'a pas
assez d'uranium 235 pour nucléarisé pour
remplacer toutes les centrales à charbon
dans le monde
donc il faut passer à l'exploitation de
l'uranium 238 ou à lyon ou à
l'exportation du thorium et tout ça ça
fait partie de la quatrième génération
il faut avoir des réacteurs avec une
sûreté intrinsèque plus importante pour
que les conneries devanture de ville
n'arrive plus jamais tchernobyl c'est
parce qu'ils avaient un quart au
graphite
ce qu'on n'a pas en france donc
l'accident type tchernobyl en france est
totalement impossible avec les réacteurs
à eau pressurisée
heureusement c'est totalement impossible
mais il faut quand même augmenter la
sûreté passive en gros il faut que ça
devienne aussi sûr que j'ai envie de
dire n'importe quel engin où ça marche
plus ça s'arrête et puis point et c'est
possible de faire ça avec le nucléaire
est mon avis est qu'il faudrait
d'urgence lancé un programme fasttrack
en europe dans lequel conduits par la
france parce qu'il ya que la france
aujourd'hui quelles possibilités
techniques de le faire on rassemble les
anglais les scandinaves et les
finlandais les suédois les tchèques et
polonais les roumains les hongrois et
éventuellement même les espagnols qui à
mon avis diront oui autour d'un
programme fasttrack sur la quatrième
génération où l'on construit le plus
vite possible
après s'être mis d'accord deux
exemplaires de
prototype des trois ou quatre dessins
dont on pense qu'il ya vraiment un
avenir et la dent évidemment pour moi il
ya les réacteurs à sel fondu et il peut
y avoir du reste de dessin différent de
réacteurs à sel fondu on peut faire un
thermique un rapide rebond
voilà donc je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'on devrait faire une estimation
grosse maille c'est que ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous coûte aller entre 20 et
30 milliards d'euros c'est à dire moins
que ce que va nous coûter iter à
terminaison
si on veut faire huit prototypes dans en
europe qu'avec les pays devaient évoquer
je suis à peu près sûr que ça marcherait
c'est à dire que tous ignoraient pour
dire oui peut-être même que si on est
bien inspiré et même si sa façon un peu
les américains on peut faire un truc
franco-russe parce que les russes sont
en train d'avancer là dessus à toute
vitesse pour satom à un carnet de
commandes qui ferait pâlir framatome
je crois qu'ils ont 30 40 réacteurs en
commande je trouve absolument
hallucinant et le et si on fait sarah
dans aller 20 ans on a les idées claires
sur ce qu'on construit en tête de série
sur la quatrième génération
la fusion en aucun cas il n'y a en aucun
cas peut nous permettre de respecter ces
échelles de ces échelles de temps si on
fait de la du nucléaire de quatrième
génération à base uranium plutonium ou
thorium uranium
on a sur vos étagères en europe de quoi
tenir sans importations pendant des
milliers d'années donc autrement dit
autrement d'humanité ce trail terme
d'autres choses bien avant on est un
problème de ressources
alors on va changer un tout petit peu
maintenant de registre et aller dans les
quelques temps qui reste
nous allons parler un tout petit peu de
pétrole 1
question est ce que l'europe
j'ai vu c'est ça est consciente des
risques de diminution
d'approvisionnement pétrolier et la
réponse est non et la réponse est non
pour une raison qui est liée à une autre
question qui m'a été posée sur le
pétrole qui est comment se fait-il
que si on manque de pétrole on voit pas
ça dans le prix alors les doigts et les
deux questions sont liées
les deux questions sont liées parce que
à partir du moment où on pense qu'il ya
un lien entre le prix et le volume à ce
moment c'est normal que l'on s'attende à
ce que on monte le pétrole si le prix du
pétrole devient de plus en plus élevé de
façon indéfinie
donc si le prix du pétrole n'augmente
pas de façon indéfinie
c'est donc qu'on ne manque pas de
pétrole alors cette réaction très normal
elle est liée au fait que vous avez tous
appris en cours d'économie et moi aussi
que ya ce qui s'appelle une élasticité
entre les prix les volumes alors
l'élasticité traduit en français courant
c'est s'il y en a plus c'est moins cher
et s'il y en a moins c'est plus cher et
ce système la marche sans limites et
pour les mathématiciens d'entre vous ça
veut dire que ce système et objectifs
dit autrement si tu me donnes le prix je
te donnerai le volume une seule
correspondance possible et si je te
donne le volume d'une donnera le prix il
ya qu une seule correspondance possible
malheureusement dans la valley ça ne
marche pas c'est à dire que si vous
regardez dans le passé ce qu'a été la
correspondance entre le prix et le
volume du pétrole sur le marché mondial
du pétrole il n'y a strictement rien qui
ressemble à une élasticité
rien de rien de rien de rien ça n'est
pas élastique
il n'y a pas de lien simple entre le
prix du pétrole et le volume de pétrole
alors une fois je vous ai dit ça je vous
ai donné une partie de l'explication qui
est qu'on peut très bien avoir un volume
qui baisse et un prix qui n'augmentent
pas alors en fait quand le volume baisse
le prix va augmenter au début au début
effectivement vous avez une élasticité
de marché et vous avez un choc pétrolier
mais une fois que vous avez eu le choc
pétrolier qu'est-ce qui se passe
il se passe que comme vous manquez de
pétrole et que le pétrole est
essentielle au fonctionnement de
l'économie
vous allez contracté l'économie vous
allez manquer de transport
en gros donc vous allez manquer de flux
intermédiaire il n'y a pas une seule
entreprise aujourd'hui qui peut
fonctionner sans transport et donc vous
allez manquer d'économies si vous
manquez d'économies vous allez manquer
de pouvoir d'achat chez les
consommateurs
donc vous allez rééquilibrer la balance
il y en a moins à vendre mais les
pouvoirs les consommateurs ont moins
d'argent pour en acheter et à ce moment
le prix du pétrole redescend à l'heure
même si on avait moins
et c'est exactement ce qui se passe en
europe depuis 2006 vous en avez moins à
acheter
mais comme le pouvoir d'achat net des
consommateurs a tendance à baisser le
prix à la pompe ne s'envolent pas je
vais vous le dire encore autrement les
un peu moins de gens qui ont les moyens
de rouler en voiture un peu plus de
classes moyennes supérieures qui ont les
moyens de rouler en suv c'est un drame
mais un peu moins de gens ont les moyens
de rouler en voiture et donc à ce moment
là vous avez un peu moins de gens qui
passent à la pompe
et comme par ailleurs le prix du pétrole
est monté les constructeurs ont fait
quelques efforts ont vendu des voitures
un peu plus petit et donc le prix à la
pompe n'augmente pas parce que vous avez
un peu moins de demande à la pompe
voilà c'est exactement ça alors du coup
retour à la question initiale donc ça ça
répond à la question qui est pourquoi
est ce que le prix du pétrole peut ne
pas s'envoler alors que l'on en manque
encore une fois la réponse c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'élasticité et la raison
pour laquelle n'ya pas d'élasticité
c'est parce que le pétrole est
indispensable au fonctionnement de
l'économie
dit autrement si vous n'avez pas assez
de pétrole ça ne laisse pas la capacité
à acheter du pétrole constante si ça
l'est c'est la capacité à acheter du
pétrole constante c'est à dire le pays
des constant effectivement le prix
devrait s'envoler de façon indéfinie
mais c'est pas ça qui se passe la
deuxième l'indicateur économique qu'il
faut surveiller pour savoir qu'on va
manquer de pétrole
il n'est pas dans le prix du pétrole il
est dans les investissements nécessaires
pour faire sortir un baril de terre j'ai
eu comme certains d'entre vous le savent
peut-être l'immense honneur de préfacé
le livre c'est vrai c'était vraiment un
prêt en honneur parce que c'est un des
livres qui m'a le plus marquée de
préfacer une version mise à jour mais
que je trouve moins bonne que l'édition
originale soit dit en passant de
limitrophes qui a été écrit par mail aux
meadows windows et un certain nombre
d'autres auteurs en 1972 72 pour les
belges qui devrait pas abandonner le
nucléaire a encore dérapé
il est suisse qui devrait pas domaine
nucléaire en plus il ne voulait rater
donc
en 72 d'avis tout golfe qui
a été quand même un coup de tonnerre à
l'époque et il a rappelé en rock le
monde était fier et puis après il ya eu
un livre qui s'est appelée la faute des
world days qui a été traduit en français
et donc j'ai fait la préface est encore
une fois c'est vraiment un des trucs
dont je suis un peu plus cher mais j'ai
quand même et ça va donner l'occasion de
rencontrer meadows à l'occasion d'une
conférence qu'il était venu faire pour
le lancement de l'édition française et
on discute a justement de cette histoire
de prix et de volumes et meadows m'a dit
un truc qui depuis une évidence donc ce
que je vais vous dire c'est lui qui n'a
expliqué il m'a dit dans un monde qui
commence à banquiers d'une matière
indispensable pour le fonctionnement de
l'économie
alors c'est vrai aussi pour les métaux
c'est pas nécessairement le prix qui
s'envolent que vous allez voir
apparaître ce que vous allez voir
apparaître c'est une augmentation
indéfinie du besoin en capital pour
extraire une unité marginal de
l'environnement donc si vous pensez que
le pétrole se raréfie
ce que vous devez voir apparaître c'est
que les investissements qu'il faut faire
pour extraire un baril de pétrole de
terre augmente et on parle pas en
l'occurrence ces cas quand vous regardez
un puits conventionnels à terre en
arabie saoudite s'était dit 1000 $ de
capex par baril jour dans les sables
bitumineux au canada c'est entre 100 et
150 mille et dans le shale oil on
n'était pas très loin ces montants là
non plus donc voilà c'est à travers ça
quand on sait que on commence à avoir un
sujet sur l'approvisionnement en pétrole
c'est exactement la même sur le même
sujet avec les métaux la baisse en métal
dans les minerais donc la baisse de la
teneur en métal dans les minerais
augmente les investissements qui sont
nécessaires pour extraire une tonne de
métal de la mine et c'est comme ça qu'on
voit se marquer la raréfaction relative
puis absolue d'une ressource qui est
nécessaire au fonctionnement du soleil
donc j'en reviens à ce que je disais il
n'ya pas d'élasticité prix volume alors
nos dirigeants de la commission et nos
dirigeants politiques dans les divers
pays d'où est ce qu'ils sortent ces
braves gens ils sortent pas du monde des
ingénieurs et ils sortent pas du nombre
des physiciens qui ont à peu près
compris ce que je viens de vous raconter
et même du raisonnement des ingénieurs
il ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas
compris ce que viens de vous raconter
faut pas qu'il soit bête mais ils sont
jamais tombés en face de l'explication
on a quand même énormément de homo
economicus dans cette histoire là et
donc homo economicus comme il a appris à
l'école qui avait une élasticité il
et tant que le prix n'augmente pas ce
que j'ai pas de prix et de
l'approvisionnement je vois pas pourquoi
je m'emmerdais à me poser la question de
savoir s'il ya une sécurité
d'approvisionnement à gérer donc on se
pose un tout petit peu la question sur
le gaz parce qu'on a bien compris qu'on
avait plein qui venait des russes etc
les russes de temps en temps on est
susceptible d'avoir une petite crise de
couple avec eux mais par contre sur le
pétrole tout le monde s'en fout j'ai
rencontré il ya quelques années le
directeur général de la direction
générale de l'énergie à la commission
européenne et je lui ai dit il faudrait
qu'on surveille notre approvisionnement
futur en pétrole qui est en train de
décliner
il a rigolé le pape a méchamment et
répond si je crie mais voilà c'est un
non sujet absolu si vous voulez en
parler en france certains d'entre vous
ont peut-être vu passer le petit poste
que j'ai fait récemment j'ai cherché le
veau pétrole dans le discours d'edouard
philippe à l'assemblée il n'y figurent
pas les chercher le veau pétrole dans la
loi de transition énergétique n'y figure
pas donc tout le monde s'en fout mon
sujet absolu donc les gens n'ont
absolument pas compris ce qui met à
l'est une demi heure d'explications à
une personne un peu attentive le pétrole
pilotes les transports les transports
pilote d'économie donc la quantité de
pétrole pilote l'économie est bien une
personne un peu attentif comprends ça en
une demi heure j'ai des explications
intermédiaires et bien au sein des
gouvernements européens que je connais
en tout cas je n'ai jamais vu passer de
discours là dessus alors que pourtant
c'est déjà à l'oeuvre
vous avez sur mon site à une page qui
s'appelle l'italie un cas d'école si ma
mémoire est bonne où j'explique que ce
qui arrive aux italiens c'est juste la
décrue pétrolière dans un pays qui était
dépendant à 50 % du pétrole dans son mix
énergétique primaire en 2006 et la grèce
qui était dépendante à 60% du pétrole
dans son mix énergétique primaire en
2006 a suivi la plus grosse dégringolade
de tous les pays européens depuis 2006
et c'est pas un problème que les grecs
payent leurs impôts ou pas si les grecs
payent pas leurs impôts c'est juste un
transfert de rente
il ya moins d'argent pour les tant et
plus pour eux donc ils vont dépenser
autrement non le vrai sujet c'est que il
se sent qu'ils se sont pris une quasi
division par 2 sur leurs
approvisionnements pétroliers et donc
toutes choses égales par ailleurs ils se
sont pris 30% son pib voilà fermez le
ban les mêmes effets les mêmes causes
ont produit les mêmes effets donc c'est
évident c'est une des raisons qui me
fait penser que la voiture balai de la
contraction pétrolière va toucher
l'europe de manière par
culièrement dur et c'est pour ça que
l'europe a particulièrement intérêt à se
creuser les méninges pour trouver une
bonne manière de décarbonés quoi que
fassent les autres pays de toute façon
parce que c'est à nous d'être pari de
pascal gagnant si on ne fait pas on perd
de toute façon et si on le fait on a une
petite chance de gagner et je vais alors
après vous avez des questions hakuna
matata alors hakuna matata c'est ne
devrions nous pas profiter de la vie
comme elle est et par la suite les
humanités laisser faire son chemin
eh bien j'ai une très bonne nouvelle
pour la personne qui m'a posé cette
question n'est ce pas exactement ce que
nous sommes en train de seconde
voyons-nous pas oui c'est exactement ce
qu'on fait c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on cherche à s'en mettre jusque derrière
les oreilles
le plus possible et savoir ce qu'il va
se passer derrière on s'en fiche un peu
quels projets dans les décisions
énergétiques et environnementales du
gouvernement assez faible directement
indirectement c'est pas par exemple je
peux revendiquer à tout petit rôle dans
le manifeste étudiants pour un réveil
écologique parce que je sais qu'une
partie des initiateurs de ce manifeste
ont notamment profité de conférences que
j'ai fait dans le monde étudiant pour
expliquer où étaient les tenants et les
aboutissants du problème et ça ça un
tout petit effet sur le monde politique
par exemple le ministre de l'éducation
favard dans le ministre l'enseignement
supérieur a vu passer stockage voilà
c'est parti gouvernement est-ce que trop
de catastrophisme peut nous amener à
baisser les bras
je crois pas je crois pas parce que il
ya une vertu à l'emploi catastrophique
de catastrophisme non c'est pas une
bonne idée par contre l'explication qui
permet de comprendre là où on en est si
elle a pour contrepartie qu'on comprend
qu'on est mal barré c'est là je pense
qu'elle est nécessaire quand même parce
qu'elle est le préalable à l'action
les quelqu'un m'a demandé si mes enfants
à l'école le vendredi j'ai passé le lien
avec greta tony berg s'est on demandé
voilà donc mes enfants vont à l'école
tous les jours mais en l'occurrence ils
sont maintenant suffisamment même plus
m'écouter
si la baie en l'opérant 620 supérieure
s'il y avait levé un avis inverse
est ce que mes activités personnelles
influence mésinterprétation est-ce que
4,24 influence plaisir interprétation
alors en fait c'est plutôt l'inversé qui
s'est passé historiquement c'est parce
que j'avais des interprétations que
dakar vodka tenais je fais partie de
cette catégorie de gens qui ont eu le
luxe de pouvoir adapter leur activité
professionnelle à ce qu'ils ont compris
du problème donc en fait
chronologiquement c'est quand ça a été
la suivante à la fin des années 90 et au
début des années 2000 je commence à
tomber sur fser je ne comprends
absolument pas ce que ça signifie je
commence à faire ce que ça n'importe qui
qui est intéressé par un sujet
c'est-à-dire creusée grant essayer de
comprendre
à l'époque j'ai la chance de pouvoir
organiser pour le compte de
l'association des anciens élèves de l'x
une série de conférences avec des gens
qui à l'époque est très disponible pour
venir je vais l'autre et consorts qui
était d'accord pour venir même si avec
15 personnes pour les écouter et les en
remercie et donc j'ai eu droit à une
formation continue de haut niveau pour
commencer à comprendre ce que c'était je
me suis pas lâché un rapport complet du
giec enfin bref j'ai commencé après je
suis tombé sur l'as paul astraud a dit
mais vous savez tous ces scénarios c'est
n'importe quoi puisque toute façon il
n'y a pas assez de combustible fossile
pour contrer le réchauffement annoncé
par le giec au gabon c'est vrai ça donc
j'ai commencé à regarder pétrole
et puis il ya des gens qui disaient
nucléaire c'est formidable ça n'est pas
de co2 du cancer grave et nucléaire et
puis une fois que j'ai regardé tout ça
mis bout à bout nous sommes au début des
années 2000 sommes 2000-2002 là et je
tombe sur la dma qui se digère bien
faire le bilan carbone enfin je vous la
résumer c'est ça et donc dit autrement
j'aimerais bien quand je serai grand
occuper de ce genre de problème et je
tombe sur le sol mais qu à l'ademe
grâce lui soit rendue pour l'éternité il
s'appelle pas berner
il s'appelle jean quintallet et il me
dit oui voilà c'est comme ça que c'est
parti donc je donc ce carbone 4 est
aujourd'hui un lointain descendant du
bilan carbone et carbone4 n'aurait pas
existé si à un moment je mettais pas
four in et dans tout ces trucs là en
ayant un intérêt c'est quand même
intéressant ce truc là et quand je serai
grand c'est ça que je veux faire donc à
la différence de ce que me reproche un
certain nombre de mes détracteurs qui
est de faire des catastrophisme pour
être capable d'en vivre
en fait j'ai fait l'inversé c'est parce
que la situation est catastrophique que
j'ai décidé de vivre de quelque chose
dont je crois que c'est utile pour
essayer d'agir dans le sens inverse et
j'assume parfaitement mais alors
parfaitement sans aucun état d'âme
le fait d'être d'avoir des relations
économiques avec un certain nombre de
gens à qui profite le crime
parce que de toute façon si la personne
à qui profite le crime vous serez tous
morts qu'on en aura toujours
donc il faut absolument qu'il y ait des
gens qui aient envie d'agir parce que à
court terme
il y voit un bénéfice autre que le
bénéfice de long terme qui est très
immatériel est très très difficile a
incarné donc ton bio qui est des gens à
qui profite le crime
tant mieux qu'ils aient des gens qui
trouvent que c'est une très bonne idée
qu'on ai la trouille du changement
climatique et donc on voyait m - pour
faire faire débat tomates de proximité
en permaculture pour faire avancer les
trains pour faire de la laine de verre
et pour faire des vélos et pour faire
des centrales nucléaires tant mieux je
trouve ça très bien du coup je vais
envoyer sur la dernière question qui est
qu'est-ce que je conseillerai à
quelqu'un qui démarre pour être utile
dans cette affaire alors il ya c'est une
question qui m'est souvent posée quand
je vais dans des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur non pas que je
sois secteur c'est que en dessous la
manière dont je m'exprime devient un peu
abscons
je n'ai pas le talent pour savoir parler
à des élèves de 3e de ce genre de sujet
d'autres l'ont donc c'est très bien
moi j'ai un type de discours ou j'aime
bien aller au fond des explications
techniques et ça s'adresse plus
préférentiellement à des gens qui sont
déjà dans le supérieur en dessous il a
un peu de mal à suivre
et moi j'ai du mal à m'adapter
donc le don qu'il demande une pose
souvent cette question et je la réponse
que je leur fais est souvent que il ya
quelques secteurs professionnels dans
lesquels on peut tout de suite mettre à
profit une compétence qui est la
compréhension du fonctionnement global
du système
j'en incarne une donc c'est pas pour
dire venez chez moi et quand même qui
est le conseil parce que le conseil est
une activité transversale ou finalement
vous faites équipes en interne avec des
gens qui connaissent bien les secteurs
d'activités dans lesquels on va
intervenir et à ce moment on est capable
de marier les deux c'est à dire à la
fois quelqu'un d'un peu seniors qui
connaît bien la métallurgie ou
l'automobile ou la paye culture ou et
cetera est quelqu'un de plus juniors qui
maîtrise ou qui veulent rapidement être
capable de maîtriser une technique qui
est rentré dans le problème donc de la
compta carbone de l'analyse de flux etc
et elle est la combinaison des deux
permet d'avancer mais des activités
transversales de cette nature vous
n'avez pas tant que ça et après il faut
directement rentré dans des secteurs
professionnels
j'ai envie de dire qu'ils sont des
secteurs qui contribuent directement ou
des activités qui contribuent
directement
alors si vous voulez décarbonés
l'existant le grand drame c'est que vous
y arrivez pas en premier job
si vous rentrez chez un constructeur
automobile et que vous savez pas comment
on fabrique une automobile ce que vous
allez mettre du temps à prendre comme on
vend une automobile ce que vous allez
mettre du temps à prendre comme
maintient une automobile ce que vous
allez mettre du temps à prendre
c'est très compliqué de rentrer ou santé
des arts et métiers uni va je veux
décarbonés le transport des gars gentil
mais tu vas commencer par savoir ce
qu'est ce que c'est une automobile donc
vous allez devoir ronger votre frein
pendant 5 à 10 ans avant d'être capable
d'avancer sur le d'avancé sur le sujet
d'ailleurs de la décarbonation c'est à
dire que vous allez devoir rentrer
demande dans une entreprise qui fabrique
des vélos qui fabrique des voitures
électriques c'est un pure player qui
fait du maraîchage de proximité qui
faire danser les trains et c'est donc là
ça veut dire qu'il faut que vous ayez
une idée de quelques activités qui
contribuent à cette affaire-là et en 10
ans chez eux
quoi que je fasse de toute façon je
ferai quelque chose qui sera utile pour
le schmilblick
et ça ça demande évidemment de faire son
tour d'horizon avant de rentrer le vous
pouvez avoir des pertes intermédiaire et
qui sont aujourd'hui il ya mené par le
manifeste
vous savez dans le manifeste étudiants
là il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
disent on n'ira pas travailler pour une
entreprise qui fait rien de sérieux sur
la question alors apprécié de
l'extérieur ce que fait une entreprise
de servir sur la question c'est
compliqué ça fait partie de mon métier
c'est passé discours qui vont vous
permettre de le savoir parce que dans
les discours tout va bien il faut un peu
rentrer dans le dur mais c'est plus
facile si vous avez une activité que
vous identifiez alors toujours pour
finir sur un sujet qui fâche si vous
vendez des éoliennes aux chinois sauf
que on voit pas beaucoup mais aux
marocains c'est très bien faut faire
aussi vous en vendez en france la puye
on sait que les moyens mais donc vous
avez des pure players qui sont des gens
qui sont capables de vous accueillir en
premier emploi beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus j'ai dit avec à ce moment un bloc
alors c'est plus facile dans les emplois
techniques
c'est très clair c'est plus facile si
vous êtes ingénieurs techniciens etc
vous pouvez encore avoir besoin soit dit
en passant d'emploi mon technique de
valeur de contrôleur de gestion etc
mais en général on en a besoin d'eux un
peu moins parce que ces gens là sont
souvent des entités pour partie sont pas
très grosse et donc vous avez une
structure transversale qui est pas très
grosse mais le contrôle de gestion chez
carbone 4 par exemple c'est pas un truc
qui est très développée au point d'avoir
besoin de quelques centaines à chaud ses
parents pas encore là
donc le voilà voilà voilà quelques
filières au niveau de l'artisanat
par exemple vous avez aussi énormément
de besoins aujourd'hui des gens qui
savent faire correctement d'isolation
par l'extérieur où l'installation pompes
à chaleur c'est des gens qui ont
l'avenir devant eux et donc si vous êtes
en filière professionnelle et bien vous
pouvez très bien aller dans ce genre de
l'activité les gens qui savent
travailler le bois
voilà donc il faut il faut identifier
ces filières et se dire quel que soit
mon niveau d'études et quelle que soit
mon job je vais essayer de chercher dans
des entreprises qui sont actives dans
ces dans ces domaines là voila voila en
gros là la réponse que je peux faire
petit codicille sur la finance dans la
finance c'est plutôt d'abord comprendre
ce que c'est que la finance décarbonés
puis à ce moment aller chez des acteurs
qui ont envie de faire essentiellement
ça parce que décarbonés l'essentiel de
la finance je pense qu on en reparlera
encore en quelques années voilà eh bien
écoutez comme il est 9h et que je
m'étais donné comme limite
d'abord il ne me reste plus qu'à
remercier pardon j'ai commencé par
présenter de plates excuses à tous les
gens qui ont envoyé des questions
auxquelles je n'ai pas répondu
voilà c'est le sait leur ai remarqué que
depuis que je suis big lots que je porte
des lunettes
j'ai besoin de mettre ses excellentes
lunettes pour regarder les questions
comme les questions qui arrivent en
continu ses écrits en petits écrits
comme les enfants il ya longtemps les
lis mal ou peu je les ai pas traitées je
suis infiniment désolés
j'espère que l'expérience a plu à ceux
d'entre vous qui ont eu la patience de
rester jusqu'au bout
et encore une fois je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être de l'autre côté de
l'écran et donc à une prochaine fois
puisque il semblerait que cet exercice
et quelque utilité à être répétée à
intervalles réguliers
voilà pour ceux d'entre vous qui n'ont
pas grignoter devant l'écran bon appétit
et à bientôt